ओके। सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस वंस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली। एक बार मुझे बता
दीजिए सभी लोग इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल
क्लियरली।
अ गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते।
नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी। सो आई
थिंक आई एम लाइव। प्लीज एक बार कंफर्म कर
दीजिए सभी लोग। ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल सही
आ रही है। कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं है ऑडियो
वीडियो में? सो दैट वी कैन कंटिन्यू।
वेलकम सर आपकी लाइव क्लास में आपका स्वागत
है। अरे बिल्कुल
आप लोगों का भी स्वागत है मेरी लाइव क्लास
में। बताओ मुझे मुझे मेरी लाइव क्लास में
स्वागत कर रहा है कोई? दैट्स गुड। अच्छा
लगा।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। एकदम बढ़िया है
ना ऑडियो वीडियो? कोई तकलीफ तो नहीं है
ऑडियो वीडियो में? है तो बता दो। पहले ही
बता दो।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नमस्ते नमस्ते सभी को एक बार पहले कनेक्ट
हो जाने देते हैं।
लेट एवरीबडी जॉइन फर्स्ट। कई लोगों को
नोटिफिकेशन थोड़ा लेट जाती है तो थोड़ा
लेट ज्वाइन करते हैं। तो पहले आ जाने देते
हैं सबको देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग ओनली।
पहले सभी आ जाएंगे देन हम स्टार्ट करेंगे।
26 पीपल आर हियर।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते नमस्ते
आई एम फाइन आई एम फाइन
आई एम फाइन
ओके
चलिए सो बिफोर आज हम आज की सेशन स्टार्ट
करते करते हैं। उसके पहले जैसा कि मैंने
हमेशा से आपको बताया हुआ है। सिंपल आपको
क्या करना है? डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube
चैनल पे आपको जाना है। यहां लाइव सेक्शन
में आपको जाना है। लाइव में किसी भी एसओसी
की वीडियो को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। किसी भी
एसओसी की क्लास वाली जो वीडियो होगी उसको
ओपन कर लीजिएगा। उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप
चले जाइएगा। डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप जाएंगे
तो आपको दो यहां पे लिंक्स मिलेंगे। पहला
एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का दूसरा एक WhatsApp
चैनल का। आप दोनों को ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
WhatsApp ग्रुप का जो लिंक है वो एसओसी का
स्पेशल स्पेसिफिक एसओसी का ग्रुप है
जिसमें जितने भी एसओसी एंथोजियास्ट्स हैं
वो एडेड है यहां पे। आप सोच सकते हैं यहां
पे ग्रुप नंबर फोर है ये। मतलब तीन और
ग्रुप्स हैं जो फुल हो चुके थे तब ये चौथा
ग्रुप बना था। यह भी फुल होने वाला है।
यहां एसओसी के इस ट्रेनिंग के रिगार्डिंग
जो भी जो भी डिटेल्स होने वाली है, जो भी
रिसोर्सेज हैं, पीडीएफ हैं, जो भी चीजें
होंगी, सब आपको इसी ग्रुप में मिलने वाली
है। एंड अपकमिंग सर्टिफिकेशन एंड अपकमिंग
जो आपका इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन और जो भी
चीजें होंगी, सब इसी में आपको मिलने वाली
है। इसको जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। ये
WhatsApp चैनल है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी। आप
सर्च कर लीजिएगा। WhatsApp चैनल YouTube
WhatsApp के ऊपर में तो आपको मिल जाएगा।
यहां पे लगभग 12,000 डेफ्रॉनिक स्टर्स
हमारे साथ जुड़े हैं। आप भी इसके पार्ट बन
सकते हैं। क्योंकि ओवरऑल जो सबसे पहले
डेफिने नोटिफिकेशन एंड अपडेट्स आती हैं
आपको ओवरऑल हर एक चीज की हमारी साइट से वो
इसी में सबसे पहले आती है। ये Lindin
प्रोफाइल है मेरा टेक्निकल नेविगेटर। आप
इस पे आके इस पे मुझे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
मुझसे जुड़ सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो कर सकते
हैं। साथ ही में यहां पे अगर जब आप
डिफ्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे तो आपको हमारे
कंपनी का Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा। डिफ़ॉन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी। आप इस पेज को भी फॉलो
करके इसके साथ जुड़ सकते हैं। यहां पे
लगभग 21,000 डिफ़ॉनस्टर्स हमारे साथ जुड़े
हैं इस पेज के थ्रू। यहां कंपनी के
रिगार्डिंग आपको अपडेट्स एंड जो भी
डिटेल्स वगैरह है वो सब आपको इसी Lindin
पेज पे मिलेंगे जो हमारी कंपनी की है। यह
हमारा एक्स का पेज है यानी कि Twitter या
यू कैन से कि आपका एक्स पेज यह इसको आप
फॉलो कर सकते हैं यहां पे आके। यह मेरी
खुद की पर्सनल Instagram प्रोफाइल है।
नितेश सिंह हैकर यूजरनेम के साथ। तो आप इस
पे मुझसे कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं, फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। ये डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हमारी
कंपनी के Instagram हैंडल है। ये हमारी
वेबसाइट है। आप इस वेबसाइट पे आके इसको
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके
हमारे जो कोर्सेज हैं उनको एक्सप्लोर
बेसिकली कर सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे हमारा
नंबर है जिस पे आप कांटेक्ट करके हमारे
साथ जो भी क्वेरीज हैं उनको डिस्कस कर
सकते हैं। जो भी आपके क्वेश्चंस हैं वो
हमसे आप पूछ सकते हैं। साथ ही में जो भी
वीडियोस हैं जब आप वीडियोस देख लेते हैं
रिकॉर्डिंग वगैरह देखने जाते हैं तो हर
वीडियो के नीचे में यहां पे ना कहीं पे एक
हाइप का बटन आपको मिलेगा। जब आप देखेंगे
तो हाइप करेंगे तो वीडियोस को YouTube
ज्यादा रिकमेंड करती है। लोगों तक पहुंचती
है। तो उस वे में भी आप जो है हमें इस चीज
को इस पूरी सीरीज को बेसिकली सपोर्ट कर
सकते हैं। सो दैट ये सीरीज जो है मैक्सिमम
लोगों तक पहुंच पाए। दैट्स इट। मेरा यही
मोटिव है, मेन मोटिव है। बाकी आप की मर्जी
है। बट स्टिल वी विल नाउ बी स्टार्टिंग द
नेक्स्ट सेशन एंड नेक्स्ट टॉपिक विथ द
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक। एंड जैसा कि मैंने आपको
पहले बोला हुआ था कि अब जो है हमारा एसओसी
का जो रियल पार्ट है जो रियल पार्ट का
मतलब है कि ये सारी भी रियल पार्ट्स ही
थी। बट ये सारे जो टॉपिक्स मैं डील कर रहा
हूं अभी फिलहाल के टाइम में वो सब एसओसी
के लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। वेरी वेरी वेरीेंट। राइट?
इसी तरीके से एसओसी में हमने बहुत कुछ कवर
किया है। बहुत कुछ हमने पहले कवर कर लिया
है। देखो अब मैं एक नोटपैड ओपन करता हूं।
एंड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पर मैं
आपको कुछ चीजें दिखाऊंगा। ठीक है?
हमने एसओसी के अंदर में पहले हमने एसओसी
के बेसिक्स को कवर करे थे। बेसिक्स
टर्मिनोलॉजी को कवर करे थे। लाइक टीटीपीस
हो गया आपका साइबर किल चेंज जैसी चीजें हो
गई या आपका अलर्ट वगैरह ट्रैक वगैरह ये सब
चीजें हमने कवर करी थी। उसके बाद हमने
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के बेसिक्स कवर करे थे।
जो हमने साइबर सिक्योरिटी के बेसिक्स
जितने भी हमारे लिए रिक्वायरमेंट थे वो
सारे कवर कर लिए थे। उसके बाद हमने
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी का नेटवर्क का
नेटवर्किंग का हमने बेसिक जो है वो कवर
करा था जो हमारे एसओसी के लिए
रिक्वायरमेंट है। तो वो भी हमारा जो
नेटवर्किंग वाला बेसिक्स है वो भी ऑलमोस्ट
खत्म हो चुका है। आज इसकी लास्ट क्लास है।
नेटवर्किंग बेसिक का पार्ट आज आपका खत्म
हो जाएगा। इसके बाद अब इसके बाद एक टॉपिक
आपकी रह जाएगी वो है ओएस रिलेटेड टॉपिक्स।
ओएस रिलेटेड जो टॉपिक्स हैं जिसमें कि
आपका Windows
एंड Linux दोनों ही
मैं सोच रहा हूं कवर करने की। ये टॉपिक एक
रह जाएगी। ये टॉपिक करेंगे। एंड उसके बाद
हमारे पास एक दो टॉपिक और है। जैसे डीएनएस
है, डीएनएस फुटप्रिंटिंग है एंड एपीटी है।
एडवांस पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट। ये जो टॉपिक्स
हैं ये हम खत्म कर लेंगे। इसके बाद हमारा
सब कुछ यह जो असिस्टिव टॉपिक्स हैं जो
बिंग एंड एसओसी आपको जाननी चाहिए। बिंग
एंड एसओसी आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है वो सारी
खत्म हो जाएंगी। एंड हो जाएंगी। देन हम हम
स्टार्ट करेंगे लॉग्स एंड एसआईएम एंड
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट अदर प्रैक्टिकल जो
एस्पेक्ट्स हैं एसओसी के। हमारे
प्रैक्टिकल की तरफ। हालांकि उनमें भी
थ्यरीज़ होंगी। उनमें भी कॉनंसेप्ट्स
होंगे। पहले हम कॉनंसेप्ट्स करेंगे। फिर
हम प्रैक्टिकल पे जाएंगे। हम
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पे जाएंगे। लैब्स के थ्रू
हम उसको कवर करेंगे। लैब्स वगैरह हम उसमें
देखेंगे। कैसे हम लैब्स के थ्रू एक-एक चीज
को समझेंगे। क्योंकि देखो लैब्स के थ्रू
समझने में फायदा ये होता है कि आप लैब्स
पे एक ओवरव्यू आपको मिल जाता है। एंड देन
आप जो है उसी चीज को रियल वर्ल्ड में जब
अप्लाई करते हैं तो आपको एक अच्छा रिजल्ट
मिलता है। आपको हर चीज की समझ आ जाती है।
तो आप हैंड्स ऑन जब करेंगे ना आप
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे, डेमोंस्ट्रेशन करेंगे
एंड प्रैक्टिकल उस चीज की जब आपके सामने
होगी तो आपको ज्यादा और ज्यादा अच्छे से
समझ में आएगा। बट जो भी हम प्रैक्टिकल्स
करेंगे आने वाले टाइम में उन सब में आपको
ये जो टॉपिक्स मैं आपको बता रहा हूं अभी
तक और अभी आने वाले कुछ क्लासेस में आपके
खत्म होने वाले हैं ये सबका बहुत बड़ा
इंपॉर्टेंट रोल है। इट दीज़ आर वेरी
वेरीेंट क्योंकि इनके बिना आपको वो
प्रैक्टिकल्स किसी आपके काम के नहीं
रहेंगे। जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग तो बिल्कुल
आपकी नहीं हो पाएगी कंप्लीट। इस बात की
मैं गारंटी लेता हूं। अगर आपकी थ्योरी
नहीं है कंप्लीट तो। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। नहीं। OS में Mac नहीं होगा। होगा वो
इसमें ओनली Windows एंड Linux होंगी। ओनली
Windows और Linux क्योंकि जो भी कंपनीज़
होती हैं Mac सिस्टम यूज़ नहीं करती हैं।
पहली बात मैं आपको क्लियर कट बता देता
हूं। जब भी कोई प्रोडक्शन में या कोई
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में कंपनीज़ यूज़ होती हैं वो
बेसिकली Mac नहीं देखो Linux बेस्ड ही
होता है। Mac भी आपका जो होता है वो Linux
बेस्ड ही होता है। तो Mac कोई सिस्टम का
हमें एसओसी पढ़ने की जरूरत नहीं है या हमें
कुछ पढ़ने की जरूरत नहीं। उसका कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। एक्चुअली आपके रियल
वर्ल्ड में कभी जिंदगी में आपकी इसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होगी। तो वो फर्जी चीज़
है। उसको हटा दो, साइड कर दो। आपको जरूरत
है Windows और Linux एनवायरमेंट को समझने
की। दैट्स इट। Windows तो अपना Windows हो
गया। Linux पे आपका जो भी आपका Mac हो गया
या Android का कर्नल हो गया या कुछ भी हो
गया वो सब ऑलमोस्ट Linux पे ही बेस्ड है।
आपका Linx कर्नल पे ही बेस्ड होता है। तो
आपको उतना टेंशन नहीं है। आपको ये दोनों
चीजें कवर्ड है। मतलब एवरीथिंग इज़ कवर्ड।
यू आर जॉब रेडी। बस बात खत्म। ठीक है?
इतना ही है। चलिए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर, ऐसे ही आप जल्दी-जल्दी वीडियो लेकर
आते रहिए। जॉब लगना है जल्दी ही वो तो मैं
वीडियो तो मैं और भी जल्दी लेकर आता लेकिन
यह सब आप लोगों की ही कृपा है कि वीडियोस
में लेट पहले भी हुए हैं और अगर फिर कभी
अगर होते हैं तो वो आपके कारण ही होंगे।
मेरे कारण कभी भी वीडियोस डिले नहीं हुए
हैं। आपका अभी लास्ट जो वीडियो थी लास्ट
क्लास उस पे तो 100 कमेंट्स भी नहीं
फुलफिल हुए थे। आपने देखा होगा जब मैंने
मैसेज डाला था उसके बाद लोगों ने कमेंट
किया था उस पे काफी सारे तब जाके वो 100
हुआ था। बट स्टिल मतलब सोचो कैसा सोच के
भी अजीब लगता है। एंड दैट्स व्हाई नोबडी
ब्रिंग्स द फ्री क्लासेस। आपको पता ही
होगा कोई भी फ्री क्लासेस नहीं लाता। कई
लोग स्कैम करते हैं। कई लोग पागल बना देते
हैं। 20 25-25,000 लेके कुछ नहीं बताते।
तो वो जानते हैं कि जो लर्नर्स हैं उसमें
1% ही है सीरियस वाले जो बहुत सिंसियरली
पढ़ते हैं। बाकी 99% को वो लोग बेवकूफ
बनाते हैं और वो लोग बनते भी हैं। तो इट्स
अ नॉर्मल प्रैक्टिस इन एडटेक। एजुकेशन
सेक्टर में यह नॉर्मल प्रैक्टिस है कि 99%
को पागल बना के उनके पैसों से 1% को
सिखाया जाए। बस यही चीज है और कुछ भी नहीं
होता है। ये जनरिक कांसेप्ट्स है। वो अलग
बात है कि हम उस चीज को फॉलो नहीं करते।
हम उस चीज में बिलीव नहीं करते हैं। बट
हमेशा मोस्टली केसेस में ऐसा ही होता है।
हो सकता है कुछ-कुछ एजुकेटर्स या कुछ
कंपनीज़ होंगी जो यूनिक थोड़ी होंगी, थोड़ी
ऑथेंटिक होंगी। ऐसी चीजें ना करती हो। बट
मोस्टली सारी यही करती है। इतना जान जाओ।
तो अब यहां पे आपकी मर्जी है वो आपको कैसे
करना है वो मुझे नहीं पता है। मुझे नहीं
पता आप में से इतने जो लर्नर्स हैं अभी जो
सीख रहे हैं उनमें से कितने लोग एक्चुअली
जॉब रेडी के लिए प्रिपेयर हो रहे हैं। अभी
देखो अभी जैसे क्लासेस हो रही है। आज संडे
है 50 लोग भी नहीं देख पा रहे सही से।
देखो स्टार्टिंग में तुम्हें पता होगा 300
लोग आए थे। फर्स्ट क्लास, सेकंड क्लास ऐसे
फिर 250 लोग थे, 200 लोग थे, 100 लोग थे।
अभी वो भी नहीं। तो दिस इज द दिस इज़ द
मैटर ऑफ टाइम कि दे डोंट गेट इंटरेस्ट।
खैर उससे मतलब नहीं है। मैंने आपको ये
पूरा एक ओवरव्यू बता दिया है कि इस तरीके
से आपको चीजें करनी है। हां। अब इसके
अलावा एक टास्क मैं आपको क्लास स्टार्ट
होने से पहले ही दे दे रहा हूं। ये क्लास
आज की स्टार्ट करेंगे। उसके मैं पहले ही
दे दे रहा हूं। ठीक है? मैं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा कि कुछ टॉपिक्स हैं।
जैसे कि मैं आपको बता देता हूं। कुछ
टॉपिक्स हैं। जैसे यह
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? ये टॉपिक्स है जिसमें कि होस्ट
लेवल अटैक्स में ये आ जाते हैं बेसिकली।
तो अभी ये होस्ट लेवल और ये सब हटा दो
बेसिकली यहां पे ये टॉपिक्स जैसे
एसक्यूएलआई, एक्सएसएस, पैरामीटर टपरिंग,
सीएसआरए, डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग ये जो
टॉपिक्स हैं इनको आप थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा खुद से। अब अगर बात यह है कि सर
एक्सप्लोर कहां से करें, क्या करें? तो
देखो ओएस टॉप 10
ओएस टॉप 10 में ये सारी टॉपिक्स कवर्ड
हैं। आप ओएस टॉप 10 को जब पढ़ लेंगे यहां
पे
ठीक है ओएस टॉप 10 को जब आप पढ़ लेंगे तो
ओस टॉप 10 में आपको सारी चीजें मिल
जाएंगी। जैसे अभी क्या है? OS टॉप 10 25
20-25। ठीक है? जो अभी करंट लेटेस्ट वर्जन
है वो 2025 है। तो आप ओएस टॉप 10 को 2025
को इसमें जब आप सारे जो लिस्ट देखेंगे 10
लिस्ट जैसे ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल हो गया,
सिक्योरिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हो गई,
सॉफ्टवेयर सप्लाई चेन फेलियर हो गया।
इनमें ही वो सारे अटैक्स जो मैंने यहां पे
आपको मेंशन किया है, वो सारे अटैक्स आपके
इनमें ही दिख जाएंगे। इनमें ही आपको मिल
जाएंगे। राइट? तो दीज़ अ यू हैव टू गो
थ्रू। एक बार आपको ना इस पे गो थ्रू करना
है। जस्ट अ सेकंड। आपको एक बार
गर्मी काफी बढ़ गई है। हालांकि मैंने तो
एसी ऑन किया है बट स्टिल इट्स टू हॉट।
ठीक है? तो ये जो टॉपिक्स हैं आपके दीज़
टॉपिक्स ये टॉपिक्स आपके वो है टॉप 10 में
मिल जाएंगे। इसके अलावा अगर आपको इसका
स्पेसिफिक वो चाहिए काइंड ऑफ कि मुझे
पढ़ना है इसको एक्सप्लोर करना है वीडियो
के थ्रू तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे ये
अवेलेबल है। मैं आपको पहले ही बता देता
हूं यहां पे जब आप लाइव सेक्शन में आएंगे
जो बग बाउंट की क्लासेस हैं बग बंटी की
क्लासेस। ठीक है? मैं यहां पे बग बंटी
क्लासेस ये जो बग बंटी मैंने क्लासेस ली
है इनमें ये टॉपिक्स आपको मिल जाएंगे। जब
बग बाउंट बग बाउंटी के स्टार्टिंग के
क्लासेस में आप जब जाओगे ना स्टार्टिंग
में जब ये शुरू हुआ था स्टार्टिंग में तो
आपको सब मिल जाएगा। लाइक काइंड ऑफ़ जो
मैंने आपको अभी यहां बताया जैसे देखो
एलएफआई वगैरह आपको मिल जा रहा है यहां पे
एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन एसएसआरएफ आपको मिल जा
रही है एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन आपको मिल जा रहा
है यहां पे अ देन आपको एक्स आईडीओआर मिल
जा रही है एचटीपी हेडर्स के बारे में यहां
पे है सीएसआरएफ मिल गई एक्सेस मिल गया
आपको ठीक है एंड मैप वगैरह स्कैनिंग वगैरह
ये सब मिल गई तो ये जो कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट कुछ
लाइक कॉमन टॉपिक्स हैं इन टॉपिक्स को आप
जो है वो गो थ्रू एक बार कर लीजिएगा ये
सारे टॉपिक्स आपको बग बंटी के हमारे जो
सीरीज है स्टार्टिंग से देखिएगा उसमें
आपको मिल मिल जाएंगे। फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट आप
इसको सीख बट बग बंटी वाली में बहुत इन
डेप्थ बताया गया है। उतना इन डेप्थ नहीं
लेना है आपको। अब जैसे एसक्यूएल आई
एक्सक्यूएल इंजेक्शन के बारे में। तो
एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन बेसिकली एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन क्या होता है? बस और कैसे काम
करता है? मतलब कैसे चीजें वर्क करती है
इसके अंदर? बस यही देखना है आपको। हल्का
ओवरव्यू लेना है। बेसिक्स का आईडिया लेना
है। एज एसओसी आपको इन डेप्थ नहीं जाना है।
बट यू हैव टू टेक अह अह अह ओवरव्यू ऑफ़ दीज़
टॉपिक्स। बस यह आप कर लीजिएगा एज़ अ टास्क।
और इसके मेन पॉइंट्स जो है आप मेंशन कर
दीजिएगा Lindin पे। एंड टैग कर दीजिएगा
मुझे। ठीक है? डिफ्रॉनिक्स को टैग
कीजिएगा। मुझे मत टैग कीजिएगा। चलिए। ओके।
ओके। अब जो है हम आते हैं यहां पे। अ नाउ
लेट्स मूव टू द नेक्स्ट टॉपिक। फायरवॉल तो
आपका Sujoy आज ही कवर आपका होने वाला है।
फायरवॉल लinक्स तो आपका जब ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम करेंगे सब कवर हो जाएगा। टेंशन मत
लो आप। बायस स्क्रिप्टिंग हम स्पेसिफिक
उसका कोई ऐसी कुछ रिक्वायरमेंट अभी फिलहाल
आपकी आपकी नहीं है। बट जब होगी तो आपको
बता दिया जाएगा। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आज की जो हम
टॉपिक है उसको स्टार्ट करते हैं। एंड दिस
इज द टॉपिक। आज हम कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग अ यहां
पे टॉपिक्स को देखने वाले हैं। एंड इसी के
साथ हमारा नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट आज हम ओवर
कर देंगे। नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट हमारा खत्म
हो जाएगा। ठीक है? उसके बाद हमारा एक ओएस
एंड कुछ एक साइबर सिक्योरिटी के एक दो
टॉपिक रहेंगे। वो बच जाएंगे। उसके बाद
आपका यह सेक्शन पूरा खत्म हो जाएगा। देन
जो है हमारा प्रैक्टिकल वाला शुरू हो
जाएगा। मोस्टली मान के चलो कि एक क्लास
आपकी और लगेगी जिसमें अ आपका
एक और जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी टॉपिक है वो लग
जाएगा डीएनएस वगैरह के बारे में और ओएस
वाली जो हमारी क्लासेस हैं उसमें आप मान
के चलो फोर टू फाइव क्लासेस लगेंगे। बस
फोर टू फाइव क्लासेस में आपकी वह कंप्लीट
हो जाएगी जो ओएस वाली हमारी पार्ट है।
उसके बाद हमारा एसआईएम वाला और जो
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन पार्ट है उसमें
मान के चल लो आपकी टोटल 10 क्लासेस
लगेंगी। टोटल 10 क्लासेस एंड उसके बाद
आपका एसओसी कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। मतलब आप समझ
रहे हो 10 + 5 15 और एक 16 15 से 16
क्लासेस आपकी और मान के चल लो बची हुई है।
जैसे अभी कितनी क्लासेस हैं? अभी तो आपकी
आज जो है 17 क्लासेस हैं। मान के चल लो 35
क्लास तक 17 क्लासेस हो चुके हैं। 15 से
16 क्लासेस और होंगी अब जो बची है और
उसमें उसके बाद आपका एसओसी कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा एल वन के लिए। याद रखिएगा दिस इज़
नॉट एसओसी एल2 ट्रेनिंग। ये एल1 ट्रेनिंग
है। तो एल1 का आपका ट्रेनिंग जो है हमारे
साइड से कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। उसके बाद कुछ
एक दो सेशंस होंगे इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन के
जैसा कि मैंने आपको प्रॉमिस किया था। और
फ़दर जो एग्जाम्स वगैरह के मैंने बोला था
कि हम एग्जाम भी लेंगे। इसका आप एक
सर्टिफिकेशन भी आपके लिए लेकर आएंगे तो वो
भी आपके लिए जो भी डिटेल्स है आपकी ग्रुप
में ही अनाउंस हो जाएगी जो ग्रुप्स मैं
बोलता हूं जॉइन करने का एसओसी का फिर आपका
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा राइट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं सर एक्स एसआईएम
एक्सडीआर ईडीआर ये सब करना देखो जोज चीजें
आपको एसओसी एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए
रिक्वायरमेंट है जो रिक्वायर्ड है वो सब
चीजें चीजें कवर होंगी। वो टॉपिक्स का नाम
टॉपिक्स के नेम से कुछ नहीं होता है।
टॉपिक्स के नेम ऐसे 50 टॉपिक मैं बता
दूंगा आपको जो इसके चीज़ के अंदर में होता
है। अभी तक तो आप आपके अगर मैं देखूं
टॉपिक वाइज़ तो 200 से ज्यादा टॉपिक्स तो
मैंने अभी तक पढ़ा दिए आपको। तो टॉपिक्स पे
मत जाओ। टॉपिक हटाओ। जोज चीजें इसमें
रिक्वायरमेंट होगी। जो एक आपको एसओसी एल1
जॉब रोल के लिए जब आप अप्लाई करने जाते हो
उस समय इंटरव्यू के टाइम में या
रिक्वायरमेंट जो वहां पे इंडस्ट्री में जो
चीजें चाहिए होती है ना सेम चीज जो है
आपको सारी चीजें कवर हो जाएंगी। तो
बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए। ठीक है? ये तो आपको
क्लियर हो गया होगा कि अब 15 16 क्लासेस
में और खत्म हो जाएंगी आपकी एवरीथिंग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए ठीक है। बढ़िया है। नाउ लेट्स
स्टार्ट। अ
58 पीपल आर हियर वेरी वेरी वेरी
सैड थिंग आई थिंक चलिए आज हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं। सबसे पहले हमें जानना है राउटर के
बारे में। आज की जो टॉपिक है बहुत ज्यादा
लें्थी टॉपिक्स नहीं है। बहुत छोटे-छोटे
टॉपिक्स हैं बट बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। इन सब
देखो इन सब टॉपिक्स का बताने का सिंपल सा
लॉजिक क्या है मेरा? आपको अभी तक अगर समझ
में आ गया होगा तो अच्छी बात है। नहीं आया
तो मैं बता देता हूं। लॉजिक सिर्फ इतना है
कि इन टॉपिक्स से आपको फमिलियर कराना।
दैट्स इट। इनका मास्टर नहीं बनना है आपको।
आपको राउटिंग का आपको जैसे मैं आज राउटर
पढ़ा रहा हूं तो राउटिंग का या स्विच
स्विचिंग का ये सब का मास्टर नहीं बनना
है। यू हैव टू नो दीज़ टॉपिक्स। यू हैव टू
नो व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग एक्सैक्टली। वो क्या
होता क्या है? कैसे काम कर रहा है? बस
दैट्स इट। इससे ज्यादा कुछ नहीं चाहिए।
आपको एसओसीएल वन के लिए इतना ही चाहिए। बस
इतना ही मुझे पता है। ठीक है? चलिए व्हाट
इज अ राउटर? सबसे पहले तो बात करते हैं।
हम राउटर के बारे में समझते हैं। राउटर
क्या होता है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो आपके घर में जब भी आप इंटरनेट
ब्रॉडबैंड कनेक्शन वगैरह लगवाते हैं तो
वहां पर एक राउटर आपका लगाया जाता है।
राइट? आपका एक राउटर होता है जो आपको
कंपनी वाले लगा जाए। Jio का आप एयर फाइबर
लगा रहे हैं या Jio का फाइबर लगा रहे हैं।
Airtel का फाइबर लगा रहे हैं तो एक राउटर
डिवाइस लगा के जिसमें ऐसे मतलब किसी-किसी
में एंटीना होती है। किसी-किसी राउटर में
एंटीना नहीं भी होती है। तो एक राउटर लग
जाता है आपके। तो राउटर बेसिकली करता क्या
है? आपके घर के नेटवर्क को आपके बाहर के
नेटवर्क से मतलब आपका जो घर का नेटवर्क है
उसको बाहर के इंटरनेट से कनेक्ट करता है।
बस अब जो घर का लोकल नेटवर्क है उसको हम
क्या बोलते हैं? उसको हम लन बोलते हैं।
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क और बाहर के नेटवर्क को
इंटरनेट बोलते हैं। और बीच में आपका आ
जाता है राउटर जो बीच में आके राउटिंग का
काम करता है। मतलब कि आपके डायरेक्शन आपको
बताता है कि भैया इधर से निकल के उधर जाओ,
उधर से निकल के उधर जाओ। रूट बनाता है।
आपको एक रूट दिखाता है। बस दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
वाओ बहुत अच्छी बात है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ट्रेनिंग वन मंथ यह तो पता नहीं 1 मंथ की
क्या है।
बिल्कुल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल सही बात है।
पब्लिक आईपी और प्राइवेट आईपी के बीच
ब्रिज का काम करता है। यस आई यू कैन से
दैट करेक्ट है। बेसिकली अंदर के नेटवर्क
को बाहर के नेटवर्क से जोड़ता है आपका
राउटर। बस बात खत्म। इतना ही है। राउटर
वर्ड राउटर राउट्स पैकेट्स बेस्ड ऑन आईपी।
अब थोड़ा सा टेक्निकल अगर जाएं तो IP पे
बेस्ड जो है पैकेट्स को रूट करता है। मतलब
पैकेट्स को एक रूट से दूसरे रूट में लेकर
जाता है। मतलब इंटरनल से एक्सटर्नल में
लेकर जाता है। परफॉर्म्स नेट नेट का
परफॉर्मेंस करता है। नेट परफॉर्म करता है।
नेट का मतलब होता है नेटवर्क एड्रेस
ट्रांसलेशन। नेट का मतलब होता है नेटवर्क
एड्रेस ट्रांसलेशन। तो यह क्या करता है?
पब्लिक आईपी में कन्वर्ट करता है।
प्राइवेट IP को माने प्राइवेट IP को
पब्लिक से कनेक्ट करता है। मतलब देखो
नेटवर्क एड्रेस ट्रांसलेशन है ये। ये
कन्वर्ट नहीं हो रहा है। यहां पे
ट्रांसलेट हो रहा है। मतलब प्राइवेट आईपी
टू पब्लिक आईपी ये करता है। जैसे आपकी
प्राइवेट आईपी है। अब इस प्राइवेट आईपी को
आप इंटरनेट से जब कनेक्ट करते हो तो एक
पब्लिक आईपी से कनेक्ट करते हो। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। तो उस प्राइवेट आईपी को पब्लिक
आईपी से कनेक्ट करने का काम करवाता है
आपका राउटर। एंड एक राउटिंग टेबल मेंटेन
करके रखता है जिसमें कि पब्लिक टू
प्राइवेट का एक टेबल होता है। राउटिंग
टेबल बेसिकली होती है। जैसे किससे किसको
करके कनेक्ट करना है। किस किस पर्टिकुलर
नेटवर्क को किससे कनेक्ट करना है। ये एक
पूरा टेबल जनरेट करके रखता है। ये काम है
आपके राउटर का। अगर मैं इमेज में आपको
दिखाऊं तो यहां पे इमेज में आप देख सकते
होंगे कि एक यहां पे पीसी है। एक पीसी
यहां पे है। ये लाइन कनेक्शन है। ये दोनों
जो पीसीज हैं वो स्विच से जुड़े होते हैं।
जैसे एक लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में। स्विच का
काम होता है लन में। स्विच कभी भी वैन
में, वाइड एरिया नेटवर्क में या इंटरनेट
में काम नहीं करता। स्विच हमेशा लाइन में
ऑपरेट करता है। लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में।
तो यहां पे स्विच के साथ बहुत सारे दूसरे
डिवाइसेस जुड़े होते हैं। जैसे एक स्विच
हुआ। अब एक स्विच के साथ जैसे बड़ी
नेटवर्क है, बड़ी कोई नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर है तो वहां स्विचेस लगे
होते हैं। मल्टीपल स्विचेस लगे होते हैं।
अब एक स्विच से दूसरा स्विच भी कनेक्ट हो
सकता है। फिर उससे मल्टीपल कंप्यूटरटर्स
या एंड पॉइंट्स या लैपटॉप्स या दूसरे
डिवाइसेस कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। तो यहां पे
आप देख सकते हो कि एक स्विच से मल्टीपल
कंप्यूटरर्स कनेक्टेड है और फिर इस स्विच
जो ये स्विच है हमारा राउटर से कनेक्टेड
है हमारा और फिर जो है हमारा राउटर वो
इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड है। या कुछ ऐसा भी हो
सकता है कि क्या होगा कि राउटर जो है फिर
से एक दूसरे स्विच से कनेक्टेड है जो कि
एक दूसरे राउटर से कनेक्टेड है। फिर यह एक
स्विच से कनेक्टेड है और इससे फिर मल्टीपल
अदर एंड पॉइंट्स या पीसीस कनेक्टेड हैं।
तो ये एक इंटरकनेक्टेड नेटवर्क हो गया
जहां पे एक राउटर के थ्रू दूसरे स्विच के
थ्रू फिर से एक राउटर के थ्रू मतलब
बेसिकली दिस इज़ एन इंटरकनेक्टेड नेटवर्क।
ठीक है? जैसे कि आप दो चीज़ें दो तरह की
नेटवर्क्स होती हैं। एक होती है इंटरनेट
और एक होती है इंटरनेट। तो इंटरनेट जो
होता है वो आपका एक इंटरकनेक्टेड नेटवर्क
होता है जो आपका एक एक ही पर्टिकुलर एरिया
में जो एक खुद का एक एक होम नेटवर्क आप
बोल सकते हो वो आपका इंटरनेट हो जाता है।
इंटरनेट क्या होता है? एक पब्लिक नेटवर्क।
पब्लिक नेटवर्क का मतलब है बेसिकली एक ऐसी
नेटवर्क जो बाहर की दुनिया से या बाहर के
कंप्यूटरटर्स बाहर के सर्वर्स से आपको
कनेक्ट कराती हो। और इंटरनेट आपके इंटरनल
नेटवर्क्स का एक पूरा का पूरा नेटवर्क
बनाती हो। एक कम्युनिकेशन कराती हो
डिवाइसेस का इंटरनल नेटवर्क के अंदर में
और हमारा इंटरनेट इंटर इंटरनेट क्या हो
गया जो एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क के साथ
कम्युनिकेशन कराती हो। तो बेसिकली जो आपका
राउटर है वो इस तरीके से कनेक्ट होता है।
स्विच के थ्रू कनेक्ट होता है या अगर आपके
पास जैसे आपका होम नेटवर्क है छोटा सा नेट
जैसे अब मैं घर में यूज़ कर रहा हूं तो
स्विच की जरूरत नहीं है। तो मैं डायरेक्ट
क्या होगा? मेरा जो पीसी है वो राउटर से
कनेक्ट होगा और राउटर हमारा जो है बाहरी
इंटरनेट से यहां पे कनेक्ट हो जाएगा।
दैट्स इट। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड राउटर। ये राउटर
का काम है। ये राउटर होते हैं। ठीक है?
अब राउटर का अगर एसओसी के लॉग देखा जाए।
राउटर में और कुछ खास स्पेसिफिक बहुत
ज्यादा डिटेल अंदर घुसना नहीं है। हालांकि
अपने आप में बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक है राउटर बट
हमें जो चीज चाहिए हमें वो जानना है।
कंसेप्ट्स हमारे दिमाग में बिठाना है।
दैट्स इट। इसके अलावा कुछ भी नहीं चाहिए।
अब लॉग्स जो एसओसी लॉ्स है राउटर से वो
किस तरह के लॉग्स निकल सकते हैं? तो सोर्स
आईपी, डेस्टिनेशन, आईपी, ट्रैफिक फ्लो ये
सब जो है राउटर से लॉग्स निकल सकते हैं।
और एसओसी का अगर इंडिकेटर इंडिकेट करेगा
तो किस तरह के इंडिकेशंस वगैरह देगा? तो
ट्रैफिक टू मलेशियस आईपी अनयूजुअल
आउटबाउंड कनेक्शंस डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन
मतलब कि बहुत सारी ट्रैफिक जो है मलिशियस
आईपी पे जा रही है ट्रैफिक हो के जा रही
है मलिशियस आईपी को जा रही है एक ऐसी आईपी
जिस पे नहीं जानी चाहिए थी ट्रैफिक
अनयूजुअल आउटबाउंड कनेक्शंस आउटबाउंड का
मतलब बाहर की हम आपकी जो लोकल नेटवर्क है
लोकल नेटवर्क यानी कि आपका जो कंप्यूटर
पीसी वगैरह है वो बाहर के किसी मशीन सर्वर
से जो है अनयूजुअली कनेक्ट हो रहा है
कनेक्शन बना रहा है और डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेशन
मतलब कि डेटा जो है वो एक्सिल्ट्रेट की जा
रही है। यानी कि डाटा जो है वह चुराई जा
रही है। डाटा जो है क्या की जा रही है?
आपकी ब्रीच की जा रही है। तो यह एसोसिएट
इंडिकेटर्स है इन केस ऑफ़ राउटर्स। राउटर्स
के साथ ही हमारा एक और टॉपिक है वो है
सबसे एक और मस्त टॉपिक है इंपॉर्टेंट वो
है स्विच। जैसे कि मैंने अभी पहले इमेज
में बताया था स्विच का गेम। अब देखो स्विच
जो होता है ये बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है।
ये बेसिकली क्या करता है ना ये कनेक्ट्स
डिवाइसेस इनसाइड अ लैंड। ठीक है? ये लैंड
के सर इंडिकेटर्स क्या याद रखना? हां
इंडिकेटर्स याद देखो याद नहीं करना होता
है बट इंडिकेटर्स जो होते हैं वो बेसिकली
आपको प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर होते हैं।
प्रैक्टिस जैसे-जैसे आप रेगुलर होगी आप
जॉब में जाओगे तो ऑटोमेटिकली आपको याद हो
जाएगा कि किस तरह के अटैक के लिए किस तरह
का इंडिकेटर होता है। कौन सा इंडिकेटर अगर
आपको मिल दिख रहा है तो किस टाइप का अटैक
हो सकता है? ये प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर होगा।
ठीक है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर वाई-फाई एंड राउटर में क्या डिफरेंस
है? थोड़ा इलेबोरेट करें। अरे भैया
वाई-फाई जो होती है वो एक टेक्नोलॉजी का
नाम है जो मतलब आप वायरलेसली नेटवर्क
वायरलेसली एक डिवाइसेस को कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। बस वही है और कुछ भी नहीं है। उसको
हम वाई-फाई उस टेक्नोलॉजी का वाई-फाई जो
आपका राउटर है वो एक डिवाइस है जैसा जो
आपके इंटरनल नेटवर्क को एक्सटर्नल नेटवर्क
से कनेक्ट करता है। राउटिंग का काम करता
है। पैकेट्स को रूट करने का काम करता है।
बहुत अलग है यार दोनों। ठीक है?
चलो स्विच क्या होते हैं? कनेक्ट्स
डिवाइसेस इनसाइड अ लोकल नेटवर्क। लोकल
एरिया नेटवर्क। मतलब जैसे मैंने पहले ही
बोला था स्विचेस क्या काम करते हैं?
मल्टीपल लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क में यानी कि
डिवाइसेस जो होते हैं आपके नेटवर्क में उन
सबको कनेक्ट करते हैं। एक मान लो एक
लैपटॉप हो गया, एक पीसी हो गया आपका कोई
भी डिवाइसेस है या एक आपका मॉडेम केबल या
टेलीफ़ोनिक मॉडेम हो गई। तो उन सबको स्विच
जो है कनेक्ट करता है एक साथ। ठीक है? तो
जैसे आपका पीसी है देन स्विच होगा एंड देन
वो सर्वर के पास अपना कनेक्ट हो जाएगा।
मतलब जो भी है आपका सर्वर या जो भी आपका
एंड पॉइंट है उससे कनेक्ट होता है। ठीक
है? एंड पॉइंट से आपका माने पीसी हो गया।
स्विच आपका हो गया बीच में जो आ जाता है
और फिर उसके बाद राउटर या बाहर की दुनिया
की जो भी नेट डिवाइसेस वगैरह होंगी वो
सारी चीजें। बट स्विच एक्चुअली करता क्या
है? देखो स्विच जो है मैक एड्रेस का यूज़
करता है एंड डेटा जो है सिर्फ करेक्ट
डिवाइसेस को भेजता है। स्विच का ये ऑपरेशन
होता है कि ये मैक एड्रेस को प्रेफर करता
है यूज़ करना। जैसे आपकी जनरली
कंप्यूटरटर्स वगैरह जो होती है तो उसमें
IPपी एड्रेस का यूज़ होता है एड्रेस के
लिए। स्विचेस में मैक एड्रेस का यूज़ होता
है। मैक एड्रेस के कांसेप्ट पे ये बेस्ड
होता है। मैक एड्रेस के बेस पे इसमें
अलग-अलग रूल्स होती हैं। अलग-अलग चीजें
होती हैं। एंड ये जो डेटा है वो बिल्कुल
ओनली करेक्ट डिवाइस को जैसे मान लो कि
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] राउटर से मान
लो इसके पास बाहर की दुनिया से कोई
रिस्पांस आया। कोई रिस्पांस आया राउटर से।
ठीक है? अब वो रिस्पांस किसको भेजना है?
एग्जैक्टली वो स्विच जो है करेक्टली
आपको भेजता है। जैसे अब मान लो इस स्विच
पे आया। अब इस स्विच से तो चारप
कंप्यूटरटर्स पीसी या एंड पॉइंट्स
कनेक्टेड है। अब वो डाटा किस पर्टिकुलर
पीसी के लिए है? किसके लिए है? वो स्विच
करता है। वो स्विच उसका स्विच का काम है
कि एकदम करेक्ट डिवाइस को ही वो सिर्फ
भेजता है। हब जो एक और चीज होती है हब। तो
हब और स्विच में ये डिफरेंस है। हब जो है
वो ब्रॉडकास्ट करने लगता है। मतलब वो ऐसा
होता है कि बेसिकली वो सबको भेज देता है
डेटा कि हां भैया आपके पास है। आपके पास
आपके हब इज़ नॉट सिक्योर एट ऑल। हब हब को
अब कोई जनरली यूज़ नहीं करता है। स्विच को
यूज़ किया जाता है आज के टाइम में जो कि
ज्यादा सिक्योर होता है। और ये जो डेटा है
मान लो रिस्पांस में कोई डेटा आ रहा है तो
जिस कंप्यूटर के लिए इंटेंडेंट डेटा है
जिस कंप्यूटर के लिए वो डेटा है इंटेंडेंट
उसी कंप्यूटर को ये स्विच जो है डेटा
भेजती है। दूसरे को नहीं भेजती है। तो इस
मैटर में थोड़ा सिक्योर भी है एंड थोड़ा
रिलायबल भी है आपका। सो दिस इज़ कॉल्ड
स्विच। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
अगर स्विच का एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव देखें तो
ये डिटेक्ट करता है इंटरनल मूवमेंट को एंड
मैक एनोमलीज़ को यानी मैक के साथ मैक
एड्रेस के साथ कोई किसी तरह का कुछ इशू
हुआ कुछ ऐसा कुछ दिक्कत हुआ एनोमलीज़ हुई
तो वो डिटेक्ट करता है और इंटरनल
मूवमेंट्स को डिटेक्ट करता है। इंटरनली जो
है कैसे डेटा मूव कर रही है? कैसे क्या वो
सब डिटेक्ट करता है। इससे रिलेटेड थ्रेट
क्या हो सकते हैं? एआरपी स्पूफिंग या मैक
फ्लडिंग हो सकती है क्योंकि ऑब्वियस सी
बात है एआरपी जो है एड्रेस रेोल्यूशन
प्रोटोकॉल उसमें भी मैक का ही रोल है और
मैक फ्लडिंग तो मैक फ्लडिंग ही है तो
इसमें ऐसे अटैक्स जो है स्विच के साथ हो
सकते हैं पॉसिबल है अब एसओसी एग्जांपल की
मैं बात करूं तो सम मैक सीन ऑन मल्टीपल
पोर्ट्स सेम मैक सीन ऑन मल्टीपल पोर्ट्स
तो इसमें ऐसा भी होता है कि कई बार क्या
होता है मैक स्पुफिंग होती है मैक
स्पुफिंग के थ्रू क्या होता है कि एक ही
डिवाइस की मैप मैक मैक एड्रेस को मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस को असाइन कर दिया जाता है टैकर
के तो इस केस में अलर्ट क्या आ सकता है कि
सेम मैक आईडी जो है वो मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस
पे या पोर्ट्स पे ऑपरेट हो रहे हैं या काम
कर रहे हैं। तो ये एक मैप एक जो है ये
क्या हो सकता है? एक एमआईटीएम या एआरपी
स्पूफिंग का एक एग्जांपल हो सकता है कि हो
सकता है यहां पे मैन इन द मिडिल अटैक हो
रहा हो या एआरपी स्पूफिंग या जो है वो
अटैक होने की संभावना बढ़ जाती है। तो ये
जो ये होता है स्विच स्विच का ये पूरा
आपका पर्सपेक्टिव था। एंड हां लाइक कर दो
भाई लोग। हां लाइक करो यार लाइक बिना लाइक
ठोके भाग जाते हैं सभी चलो कोई बात नहीं
लाइक ठोक देना ये हो गया आपका स्विच तो
हमने यहां पे राउटर एंड स्विच देखा जो कि
बहुत बेसिक चीज़ हमें जाननी थी कि राउटर
क्या होता है स्विच क्या होता है बेसिकली
स्विच कुछ इसी तरह का जैसा मैंने आपको
बताया कि बाहर की जैसे ये पूरा इंटरनेट है
फिर वो राउटर देखो नीचे से अगर ऊपर की तरफ
देखें हम यहां पे तो हमारा एंड डिवाइसेस
होते हैं एंड पॉइंट्स जो होते हैं
कंप्यूटरटर्स हो गया पीसी हो गया या मॉडेम
वगैरह हो गई उसके बाद कुछ यहां पे एज
स्विचेस होते हैं जो मल्टीपल स्विचेस होते
हैं जो कि डायरेक्ट कनेक्टेड होते हैं
हमारे पीसी लैपटॉप से। उसके बाद एक कोर
स्विच भी होता है जो सारे एंड स्विचेस को
जोड़ता है। मतलब कि एक कोर स्विच भी हो
सकती है। देखो जरूरी नहीं है कि कोर स्विच
हो ही या ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि एक कोर
स्विच से ही डायरेक्ट ये कनेक्टेड हो जाए
हमारे एंड पॉइंट्स या लैपटॉप या पीसीस
वगैरह से या अगर कोई बहुत बड़ा नेटवर्क है
तो उसमें क्या होता है कि एज स्विचेस का
यूज़ किया जाता है। जिसको फिर से कोर
स्विच जो है उससे कनेक्ट किया जाता है।
कोर स्विच एक सिंगल स्विच आपकी हो गई।
उससे मल्टीपल एज स्विचेस निकलते हैं और
उससे फिर मल्टीपल कंप्यूटरटर्स या
मॉनिटर्स सॉरी कंप्यूटरटर्स या लैपटॉप्स
या आपकी मॉडम्स यह सारी चीजें कनेक्ट होती
हैं। तो और फिर वो राउटर से कनेक्ट होता
है और फिर वो इंटरनेट आपका ये पूरा का
पूरा एक फ्लो होता है स्विचेस का।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अब
देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्लास करते-करते बहुत ऐड आता है।
डिस्टरबेंस होता है। अब ऐड का तो इसमें
मैं कुछ नहीं कर सकता। ऐड ऑटोमेटिक होती
है सुजय। उतना तो आपको करना ही पड़ेगा। ऐड
देखना ही पड़ेगा। दूसरा दूसरा ऑप्शन कुछ
नहीं है। ऐड ऑटोमेटिक आती है। वो उसका हम
कुछ नहीं कर सकते हैं। राइट? क्योंकि
हमारा ऐड एडवर्टाइजमेंट इनेबल्ड है। तो ऐड
तो आना ही है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चलो यहां पे
है वीपीए वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क। अब हम
यहां पे करने वाले हैं एक इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक। एक इंटरेस्टिंग अ जो आप सभी में से
कई लोगों का एक इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक हो सकता
है या ऐसी टॉपिक जिसके बारे में मोस्टली
सब लोग जानना चाहते हैं। वीपीए के बारे
में। ठीक है? वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
व्हाट इज वीपीए वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
देखो
वीपीए को लेके हालांकि
बहुत लोगों को पता है ऑलरेडी वीपीए क्या
होती है मैक्सिमम पीपल नो ऑलरेडी नो कि
वीpn क्या होती है एंड कई लोग वीpए यूज़ भी
कर चुके होंगे करते भी होंगे कई लोगों ने
जैसे कि वीpए जैसे प्रोटोन वीpए हो गया न
वीpए हो गया एक्सप्रेस वीpए हो गया आपका
या वॉर्p हो गई या क्लाउड फेयर का जो
वॉर्प वगैरह आता है वो सब डीएनएस वाला जो
होता है डीएनएस मैनपुलेटर या डीएनएस का तो
वो सारी चीजें लोग यूज़ करते हैं। बट यहां
पे वीpए के बारे में मैं आपको थोड़ा सा
डिटेल में बताना चाहता हूं। ठीक है? बहुत
डिटेल में ताकि आपको वो चीजें और ज्यादा
क्लेरिटी के साथ आपको समझ में आए और
ज्यादा क्लियर हो कि एग्जैक्टली वीpए क्या
होती है। ठीक है? लव फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश।
अगर आपकी जैसे पैशनेट बंदा और कुछ लोग
होते तो हर जगह पर एक साइबर वरियर होता
भैया। थैंक यू ब्रदर। थैंक यू फॉर दैट।
थैंक यू मच।
सही है गुरु जी। क्या सही है ब्रदर? मैं
समझा नहीं आपने क्या सही है बोला है। कोई
बात नहीं। फोर कल लेट हो गया। कोई दिक्कत
नहीं। चलो आ तो गए।
अरे ऐड तो ऐड आता है तो उसमें मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं? बताओ ना। ऐड देख लो थोड़ी सी
यार। ऐड देख लो। क्या दिक्कत है? लोकल
वीpए ऐप सेफ नहीं होता। बिल्कुल सही बात
है। बिल्कुल सही।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए ठीक है। लेट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] स्टार्ट। वीpए
क्या होता है? बेसिकली हम पहले इसको समझते
हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अ वीpए
क्रिएट्स अ सिक्योर इंक्रिप्टेड टनल
बिटवीन अ यूजर एंड अ नेटवर्क। वीपीए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो होता है ये
एक सिक्योर इंक्रिप्टेड टनल क्रिएट करता
है। इस बात पे फोकस कीजिएगा कि एक सिक्योर
तो करता ही करता है साथ में एक
इंक्रिप्टेड टनल क्रिएट करता है।
इंक्रिप्टेड टनल बिटवीन अ यूजर एंड अ
नेटवर्क। एक यूजर और नेटवर्क के बीच में।
बस एक यूजर और एक नेटवर्क के बीच में
इंक्रिप्टेड टनल क्रिएट करता है। अब यह
कैसे करता है? देखो, एक यूजर है आपका
पहले। फिर एक इंक्रिप्टेड टनल क्रिएट होती
है। देन वीपीए का अपना सर्वर जो वीpए
सर्वर होता है। देन आपका इंटरनेट या
इंटरनल नेटवर्क जो भी होता है वह होता है।
तो मतलब दो डिवाइसेस हैं। दो डिवाइसेस के
बीच में एक यूजर और एक सर्वर के बीच में
खड़ा हो जाता है वीपीए और एक इंक्रिप्टेड
टनल जो कि सिक्योर सिक्योर इनफ। कोई
ट्रैफिक जा रही है तो वो सिक्यर्ड क्रिएट
करता है। अब वीpए क्या करता है? ट्रैफिक
को इंक्रिप्ट कर देता है। हाइड्स रियल
आईपी। रियल आईपी को हाइड कर देता है और
अलाउज़ रिमोट एक्सेस। यह कॉर्पोरेट यूज़ में
होता है। कंपनीज़ वगैरह यूज़ करती है रिमोट
एक्सेस VPN के थ्रू। बट फिलहाल नॉर्मली आप
दो चीजों को समझिए। ट्रैफिक को इंक्रिप्ट
करना और आपकी रियल आईपी को हाइड करना यानी
कि आपके आइडेंटिटी को हाइड करना। यह बेसिक
वीpए का काम है। सिंपल। अब यहां पे वीपीए
टनलिंग कैसे काम करता है? ये देखिए। ठीक
है?
वीpए टनलिंग कैसे काम करता है? इसको आप
देखिए। वीpए टनलिंग कैसे काम करता है?
देखो वीpए टर्नलिंग में क्या होता है जैसे
आपका ये डिवाइस है एक देन आपका वीpए सर्वर
होता है एंड देन आपका जो वेबसाइट या ऐप जो
आप एक्सेस करना चाहते हैं वीpए के थ्रू वो
आपकी होती है। ठीक है? तो देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे अब यहां
पे जो आपकी डिवाइस है वो वीpए से कनेक्टेड
है वीpए सर्वर से एंड वीpए सर्वर फिर उस
ऐप या वेबसाइट से कनेक्टेड है। तो जो
डिवाइस और वीpए सर्वर के बीच आपकी जो
कम्युनिकेशन होती है वो इंक्रिप्टेड
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है यहां पे। फुल्ली
इंक्रिप्टेड होती है। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है। यानी कि आपके और वीpए के बीच में कोई
कुछ चुराना चाहे तो यह पॉसिबल नहीं है। और
जनरली वीपीए से वेबसाइट के तरफ जब
कम्युनिकेशन होती है वो मोस्टली
अनइंकिप्टेड कम्युनिकेशन होती है। अब कुछ
वीpएं जो हैं वो एंड टू एंड का भी बोलते
हैं। एंड टू एंड भी प्रोवाइड करते हैं।
लाइक कि हां भाई शुरू से लेके लास्ट तक हम
पूरा का पूरा इंक्रिप्टेड रखते हैं। कुछ
वीpएं इस अह अह चीज़ पे इस अह फंडे पे काम
करते हैं कि इंक्रिप्टेड रखेंगे डिवाइस के
साथ और इधर हम वेबसाइट्स और एप्स के साथ
अनइंक्रिप्टेड रखेंगे। कुछ वीpएं क्या
करते हैं? एंड टू एंड इंक्रिप्शन भी
अप्लाई करते हैं जो कि पूरे इस पूरे
डिवाइस से लेके पूरे इस वेबसाइट तक का जो
कम्युनिकेशन होगा वो एंड टू एंड क्योंकि
इस दोनों के बीच तो एंड टू एंड होगा ही।
अब इन्होंने अपना भी यहां पे कम्युनिकेशन
जो है वो इंक्रिप्ट करके एंड यूज़ कर लिया
है। तो ये ज्यादा वो ज्यादा एंड टू एंड
ज्यादा सिक्योर माना जाता है। ठीक है? तो
इस तरीके से वीpए टर्नलिंग आपकी काटती है।
काम करती है। अब बेस्ट वीpए हां अब कुछ
लोगों का यहां पे क्वेश्चन होता है कि सर
बेस्ट वीpए कौन सा है? सबसे अच्छा वीपीए
कौन सा है? देखो मैं आपको एक फैक्ट बता
देता हूं। ठीक है? मैं आपको एक फैक्ट बता
देता हूं। उसको
थोड़ा सा ध्यान उसको थोड़ा सा वह करिएगा।
जब मैं यहां पर Google पर जाऊंगा।
ठीक है यहां पर एंड यहां पर मैं सर्च
करूंगा
वीपीएंस
गिविंग लॉग्स टू
गवर्नमेंट मैं ऐसा कुछ कर दूं ठीक है
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] ऐसे तो यहां पे
आपको एक आंसर मिलेगा ठीक है यहां पे आपको
कुछ आंसर मिलेगा क्या है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मेजर वीpए
प्रोवाइडर्स टिपिकली हैव स्ट्रिक्ट नो
लॉगिन पॉलिसीज यह आपको एक आंसर यह मिलेगा।
बट सम हैव रिमूव्ड फिजिकल सर्वर्सर्स
फ्रॉम जरिडिकशंस वि मैंडेटरी डाटा लॉगिंग
लॉज़ सच एज इंडिया। ठीक है? यहां से हटा
लिया। द इंडियन कंप्यूटर इमरजेंसी
रिस्पांस टीम सर्ट इन डायरेक्टिव
रिक्वायर्स प्रोवाइडर टू स्टोर कस्टमर्स
नेम, IPपी एड्रेस एंड यूसेज पैटर्न फॉर
फाइव और मोर इयर्स। यह याद रखिएगा। ये
रेडिट का है। मैं आपको यहां पे रेडिट का
भी वो करके दिखा दूंगा वैसे तो। अब देखो
यहां पे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इन रिजल्ट्स में आपको मोस्टली जब देखोगे
ना तो आपको यही देखने को मिलेगा इन
रिजल्ट्स में। क्या बोल रहे हो?
अभी आप लोगों आप लोगों में से मैक्सिमम
लोगों का सभी कंफ्यूजन दूर करूंगा। अभी
वीपीए को लेके अभी मैं बताता हूं।
अभी मैं वीपीए को लेके अभी कंफ्यूजन दूर
करूंगा। ये जो वीpएं में लिखा होता है
मोस्टली कि लॉग्स नहीं होते, लॉग्स नहीं
देते। ये सारी चीजें आप देखोगे यहां पे अ
यहां पे रेडिट पे यहां पे आ रहा है कि
इंडिया में क्या होता है कि लॉग्स को रखना
होता है 5 सालों तक। कि यह गवर्नमेंट का
लॉ है। तो वीpए कंपनीज़ क्या करती है? कई
बार कि उस लोकेशन में उस पर्टिकुलर कंट्री
में अपना सर्वर ही सेटअप नहीं करती है। सो
दैट जब सर्वर ही सेटअप नहीं करेंगी तो
लॉग्स देने का कोई सवाल ही नहीं उठता है।
तो ये सारी चीजें ये पॉसिबिलिटी होती है।
कई ऐसे वीpए प्रोवाइडर जो है करती हैं कई
बार ऐसे। लेकिन होता क्या है? जिन वीpए के
सर्वर्स जो भी वीpए ऐसे वीpए प्रोवाइडर
हैं जो इंडिया में अपने सर्वर्स के साथ
काम कर रहे हैं। इंडिया में सर्वसर्स
अपॉइंट करके रखा हुआ है। सर्वर्स होस्ट
करके रखे हुए हैं। सर्वर्स को यहां
डिप्लॉय करके रखा हुआ है। उनके साथ क्या
है? उनको गवर्नमेंट का जो बेसिकली अ
डायरेक्टिव है उसको फॉलो करना ही करना है।
तो उसको क्या करना है? कस्टमर्स का क्या
करना है? नेम, IP एड्रेस, यूसेज पैटर्न यह
सब रखना है। लगभग फाइव फोर टू फाइव इयर्स
तक का रखना है। ड्यूरेशन जो भी हो बट ये
करना होता है। अब यहां पे जितने भी
वीपीएंस हैं बहुत सारे ऐसे वीपीएंस हैं
जिनका इंडिया में सर्वर है। इंडिया में
सर्वर रख के ऑपरेट कर क्योंकि एक अच्छी
परफॉर्मेंस मिलती है। सर्वर जितना पास
होता है एंड यूजर के उतनी अच्छी
परफॉर्मेंस होती है। परफॉर्मेंस से कोई
कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ नहीं करते हैं कंपनीज़। इस
वजह से उनको रखना पड़ता है एंड फिर
गवर्नमेंट के डायरेक्टिव्स के अंडर ही काम
करना पड़ता है। तो मोस्टली वीपीएंस कंपनी
जो हैं लॉग्स कलेक्ट तो जरूर करती हैं।
याद रखिएगा हां ये हो सकता है वो शेयर कुछ
वीpएं कंपनीज़ शेयर ना करती हो क्योंकि
उनका सर्वर नहीं है उस कंट्री में तो शेयर
करने के लिए वो लाइक ऐसा कुछ नहीं है कि
बाध्य हैं कि बहुत ज्यादा प्रेशराइज्ड
हैं। बट अगर कंपनीज़ उन ऐसी कंपनी जो उस
कंट्री में अपने सर्वर को होस्ट करके रखी
हुई है और उस कंट्री का ऐसा रूल है कि
आपको कस्टमर के डिटेल्स रखने हैं और 5 साल
तक जब हमें चाहिए होंगे किसी पर्टिकुलर अह
क्रिमिनल एक्टिविटी या फिर टेररिज्म के
अगेंस्ट तो हमें देना पड़ेगा। तो उसको तो
कुछ नहीं कर सकते। वो करना ही पड़ेगा। बट
वीpएं कंपनी बहुत सारी जो यह बोलती हैं
स्ट्रिक्ट नो लॉग पॉलिसी। मतलब वो खुद भी
कलेक्ट नहीं करती है। यह एक बहुत
डिस्प्यूटेड मैटर है। दिस इज़ अ
डिस्प्यूटेड मैटर। इसका कोई क्लेरिफिकेशन
नहीं मिल पाता है। किसी को भी बहुत
क्लेरिफिकेशन नहीं मिल सकती है। क्योंकि
वीपीए अब वीpए कंपनी जो है ना वो लॉग्स
मेरे हिसाब से रखती ही रखती हैं। दैट इज़ अ
डिफरेंट थिंग कि वो आगे किसको दे रही है
नहीं दे रही है। दैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग।
दैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट केस जो मैंने पहले डील
किया। लेकिन लॉग बिल्कुल लॉग ना करना यह
दिस इज़ नॉट ट्रू। मोस्टली सारे टॉप वीpए
कंपनीज़ भी लॉक करती होंगी। 100% मैं
गारंटी के साथ बोल सकता हूं। वो कई ऐसे
न्यूज़ भी आए हैं पहले जिसके मतलब बहुत
सारी ऐसी चीजें हैं जो हुई हैं जिन पे मैं
बहुत ज्यादा तो बात नहीं कर सकता बट स्टिल
कि ये एक
मिथ है मिथ गलतफहमी है लोगों की जो लोग
सोचते हैं। तो
यहां पे आप ये ये वाला रेडिट वाला ये पढ़
लीजिएगा। ये बहुत बड़ा पोस्ट है। ठीक है
ना? तो आपको समझ में थोड़ा सा आ जाएगा इसके
बारे में भी। यहां पे यहां पे भी यह
सर्विलांस का भी है वीपीएन ब्रफ न्यू
टेक्स होल्ड यहां पे यह न्यू जो लॉ है
उसके हिसाब से है तो वो भी आप पढ़ लीजिएगा
थोड़ा सा आप पढ़ लीजिएगा इसके बारे में
आपको समझ में एग्जैक्टली आ जाएगा ठीक है
ना कि क्या हो जाता है कि इंडियन ऑर्डर्स
वीpए कंपनी ये देखो यहां पे इंडिया
ऑर्डर्स ये उसी तरीके का है इंडिया
ऑर्डर्स वीpए कंपनीज़ टू कलेक्ट एंड हैंड
ओवर यूजर डेटा तो यूजर डाटा जो है अह ये
सब का है तो ये सारी चीजें होती हैं दिस
इज़ नॉट अ बिग डील ये नॉर्मल चीज़ नॉर्मल
सिनेरियो है तो द थिंग इज़ कि ये कहना कि
भैया नहीं हम तो बिल्कुल भी
लॉग नहीं रखते हम बिल्कुल एकदम
सती सावित्री बनके हैं रख रहे हुए
हरिश्चंद्र है तो नहीं चलेगा ऐसा बिल्कुल
ये ट्रू नहीं है तो जब भी आप कोई वीपीए
यूज़ करते हैं तो आप अपने रिस्क पे किया
कीजिए एंड आपकी सेफ्टी आपकी आइडेंटिटी तो
कंप्रोमाइज नहीं होगी बेसिकली आपकी
एनोनिमिटी के लिए काफी अच्छा होता है
लेकिन स्टिल आप उस पे कोई ऐसा काम मत
कीजिए कि ये सोच के कि अरे अब तो हमारे
पास वीपीए है तो हम कुछ भी कर सकते हैं।
किसी भी तरह का इललीगल प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हैं। किसी भी तरह का इललीगल काम कर सकते
हैं। कितना भी बड़ा साइबर क्राइम हम ल्च
कर सकते हैं। दिस इज़ नॉट ये सही नहीं है।
यह काम आप तो बिल्कुल मत कीजिएगा क्योंकि
यह आपके लिए बैकफायर कर सकता है। दिस दिस
इज़ नॉट राइट। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो यश इज आस्किंग सो लाइक वीpए इज नॉट
सिक्योर। यश शायद आपने मेरी बात समझी
नहीं। मैं आपको फिर से एक बार शॉर्ट में
बता देता हूं। वीpए सिक्योर होता है। वीpए
सिक्योरिटी वीपीए के सिक्योर का इससे कोई
लेना देना नहीं है। वीpए तो सिक्योर आपको
इंक्रिप्टेड कनेक्शन प्रोवाइड कर रहा है।
एंड टू एंड वाले पूरे इंक्रिप्टेड आपको
प्रोवाइड करेंगे। आई वाज़ टेलिंग ऑफ द
लॉगिंग पॉलिसी ओनली कि आपके जो डाटा रखते
हैं उसकी मैं बात कर रहा था। तो उसमें ना
वो बिल्कुल फेयर चीज नहीं है। उसमें बहुत
तरह की दिक्कतें हैं। हालांकि उस पे हम
ज्यादा बात नहीं करेंगे। अभी फिलहाल हम
आगे की तरफ बढ़ेंगे। टाइप्स ऑफ वीpए के
देखो वीpए के बहुत सारे टाइप्स होते हैं।
मैंने यहां पे शॉर्ट में आपको कुछ वीpए के
टाइप्स बताए हैं। जैसे एक होता है आपका
रिमोट एक्सेस वीpए। एक होता है आपका साइट
टू साइट वीpए। एक होता है आपका एसएसएल
वीpए। एक होता है आपका तीन जो वीpएं हैं
ये मेनली मैंने आपको बताया हुआ है रिमोट
एक्सेस वीpए साइड टू साइड वीpए एंड एसएसएल
वीpए ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे ये तीनों
बेसिकली क्या है
ये तीनों बेसिकली क्या है देखो मैं आपको
बताता हूं तीनों का थोड़ा सा डिफरेंस मैं
आपको बता देता हूं रिमोट एक्सेस वीpए जो
है वो कंपनीज़ वगैरह यूज़ करती है मोस्टली
जिसमें रिमोटली कोई चीज़ एक्सेस करते हैं
वो कंपनी वीpए प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू फॉर द
सिक्योरिटी एंड फॉर द आइडेंटिटी
वेरिफिकेशन मतलब आइडेंटिटी को वो हाइड
करने के लिए और ये सब चीजों के लिए तो यह
आपका एंप्लई कंपनी के नेटवर्क के साथ यूज़
करता है। जैसे कोई वर्क फ्रॉम होम कर रहा
है या जैसे आपने देखा होगा कि ट्राई हैक
से अगर आपको कनेक्ट करना है। ट्राईक भी एक
बाहर की कंपनी है। राइट? उसका अपना खुद का
एक नेटवर्क है। तो आपको उनसे कनेक्ट करना
है तो आप एक वीpए ही तो यूज़ करते हो। एक
ओपन वीpए के थ्रू एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के थ्रू
आप उनको एक्सेस करते हो। राइट? उसी तरीके
से दूसरे ऐसे बहुत सारे कंपनीज़ अपनी
पोर्टल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] को
एक्सेस करवाने के लिए वीpए का यूज़ करती
है। जैसे आप वर्क फ्रॉम होम कोई कर रहा
है। बाहर की कोई कंपनी है तो वो वीpए के
थ्रू ही कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। तो ऐसा भी
होता है। राइट? देन होता है साइड टू साइड
वीpए। मतलब एक ऑफिस से दूसरे ऑफिस कनेक्ट
करना हो। जैसे एक ऑफिस दिल्ली में है।
दूसरा आपका चंडीगढ़ में है तो इस ऑफिस से
दूसरे ऑफिस के नेटवर्क में कनेक्ट करना हो
तो वीpएन के थ्रू होता है। तो ये एक
एंटरप्राइज नेटवर्क बहुत बड़े-बड़े
नेटवर्क में यूज़ किया जाता है। जो कि
साइड टू साइड वीपीएन कहलाता है। उसके बाद
होते हैं एसएसएल वीपीएन। एसएसएल वीpए जैसी
क्या होता है? बेसिकली ये ऐसे एक नाम दे
दिया गया है कि ये एचटीपीएस जनरली यूज़
करती है एंड कॉर्पोरेट सेटअप में ये यूज़
में आती है। बट ये मोस्टली सारे जो वीpएं
हैं वो सब ही इंक्रिप्टेड कनेक्शन पे काम
करते हैं। इंक्रिप्टेड नेटवर्क पे ही काम
करते हैं। एचटीडीपीएस पे ही काम करते हैं।
तो ये एक आपका एसएसएल वीpए होता है। ठीक
है? नॉर्मल एसओसी पर्सपेक्टिव का देखें तो
नॉर्मल बिहेवियर में क्या होगा कि एक यूजर
आईपी देन वीपीएन आईपी देन इंटरनल सिस्टम
इस तरीके से काम करता है। नॉर्मल बिहेवियर
अगर देखा जाए तो कि यूजर वीpए के आईपी से
कनेक्ट करता है और वीpए की आईपी फिर आगे
की दूसरे नेटवर्क के आईपी से कनेक्ट करता
है। अब वीpए का बारे में बहुत लोग ये
जानते थे कि [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वीpए का यूज़ होता है ब्लॉक्ड वेबसाइट्स
को अनब्लॉक करने के लिए। बहुत लोगों के
दिमाग में ये बैठा होता है। तो ऐसा नहीं
है। वो एक इसका फंक्शनैलिटी है। इसलिए
क्योंकि वो एक कांसेप्ट इसलिए आपका है
क्योंकि आप सोचो ना ब्लॉक्ड वेबसाइट्स
अनब्लॉक वेबसाइट का कांसेप्ट क्या है कि
यह जो वेबसाइट है मान लो यह है fb.com
fb.com
अब यह मान लो fb.com जो है हमारे इस
डिवाइस नेटवर्क के लिए ब्लॉक्ड कर दी गई
है। बाय चांस तो अब यह डिवाइस जब इसको
एक्सेस करने के लिए जाएगा ना तो जब इसकी
आईपी जाएगी तो यह बोलेगा एफबी अरे भैया
तुम तो ब्लॉक हो। तुम्हें तो हम एक्सेस ही
नहीं करने देंगे। हो गया। बट जैसे ही
वीपीए बीच में आ जाता है तो अब डिवाइस का
जो रिक्वेस्ट जाएगा वो वीpए को जाएगा।
यानी इसकी आईपी वीpए के पास जाएगी और
वीपीए जब है ये अब इस डिवाइस के बिहाफ में
हमारे सर्वर को रिक्वेस्ट करेगा तो यहां
पे अब वीpए की आईपी जाएगी सर्वर के पास
वीpए की आईपी और वीpए की आईपी तो ब्लॉक है
नहीं सर्वर पे तो Facebook उसको रिप्लाई
कर देगा वीpए की आईपी को और वीpए फिर वापस
से हमारे सर्वर के बिहाफ में इस डिवाइस को
रिप्लाई कर देगा। इस तरीके से यह
अनब्लॉकिंग वाला काम होता है। कोई चीज़
ब्लॉक होती है तो वीpए लगाया तो अनब्लॉक
कर सकते हैं क्योंकि वह अब अलग हो जाता
है। राइट? सिंपल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सा फंडा है ये।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। द क्वेश्चन इज
बिल्कुल सही है। नो वन इज़ 100% सिक्योर।
सुजाता साह आई एम सर आई एम एट सेकंड ईयर
एंड आफ्टर फ्यू मंथ्स आई प्रमोटेड टू थर्ड
ईयर। डू आई गेट जॉब और ट्राई फॉर
इंटर्नशिप? थर्ड ईयर में है तो आप
इंटर्नशिप ट्राई कीजिए। एक अच्छी
इंटर्नशिप खोजिए। इंटर्नशिप का
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एक अच्छी इंटर्नशिप का पावर आप नहीं जानते
हैं। बहुत लोग नहीं जानते हैं कि एक अच्छी
इंटर्नशिप कितनी पावरफुल हो सकती है आपके
फर्स्ट जॉब के लिए। आपका फर्स्ट फ्रेशर
जॉब आपको बहुत आसानी से और अच्छे अच्छे
सैलरी के साथ दिला सकती है। अगर आपका एक
अच्छा इंटर्नशिप आपने लैंड कर लिया है। तो
जब आप थर्ड ईयर वगैरह में हैं, थर्ड ईयर
में आप कर रहे हैं तो आई रेकमेंड यू मतलब
आप प्री फाइनल ईयर में जब हैं तो एक अच्छी
इंटर्नशिप लीजिए। देन आप जॉब के लिए फाइनल
ईयर के आसपास या फाइनल ईयर के बाद कीजिए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अ ओके
संबुल खान संबुल खान समुल खान इज़ एसओसी
गुड ऑप्शन फॉर मी एज़ आई एम एन आईटी
काउंसलर [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एंड
आई रिसेंटली डन कोर्सेस लाइक सीसीएनए
एमसीएसए बेसिक Linux एज़ ऑफ़ नाउ आई डिड नॉट
गेट एनी गुड जॉब प्लीज आंसर मी। आपके लिए
एसओसी बिल्कुल बढ़िया है। आप एसओसी के साथ
जाइए एंड होपफुली आप एसओसी में जॉब लैंड
कर सकते हैं। ऑलरेडी आपको बेसिक आपकी काफी
अच्छी है। आपने काफी कुछ कर रखा है ऑलरेडी
तो आपके लिए ज्यादा प्रॉब्लमेटिक नहीं
होगा और एसओसी के लिए काफी डिमांड है।
काफी ज्यादा जॉब रिक्वायरमेंट्स काफी सारी
पोस्टिंग मतलब जो है जो ओपनिंग्स है वो
डेली बेसिस पे होती है। तो आप कर सकते
हैं। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सिद्धार्थ पाठक, सर, आई गॉट माय फर्स्ट बग
एंड आई वांट टू गिव दैट टू डिफ़्रॉनिक्स।
आई हैव टैग यू इन द Lindin आल्सो। एंड सर,
मुझे अपना फर्स्ट बाउंड्री आपको देना है
सर। अरे क्या बात है सिद्धार्थ,
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू यू सिद्धार्थ। एंड आई
एम रियली हैप्पी दैट यू गॉट योर फर्स्ट
बाउंड्री।
आप बताइए आपकी कितने की बाउंड्री लगी है
सिद्धार्थ। कितने आपकी बाउंटी कितने की
लगी है?
कांग्रेचुलेशन सिद्धार्थ। बहुत अच्छा लगा
आपका जान के। आपको बाउंट फर्स्ट बाउंट्री
लगी है। सर इंटर्नशिप कैसे और कहां पर
खोजो? देखो इंटर्नशिप आप इंटर्नशाला जैसी
वेबसाइट्स एंड नौकरी पे भी लोग पोस्ट करते
हैं। Lindin सबसे बड़ी आपकी आपकी हेल्प
करेगा सबसे ज्यादा। Lindin पे आपको सबसे
ज्यादा इंटर्नशिप आपको मिलने वाला है। आई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एम गुड।
अप्पू विश्वास आप बताइए।
सिद्धार्थ पाठक। क्या बात है सिद्धार्थ।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस। सिद्धार्थ को $2 की बाउंट
मिली है। एंड सिद्धार्थ मतलब आपकी फर्स्ट
बाउंट $200 की है। एंड आई वुड आई वुड से
कि इससे मुझे आपके मतलब बाउंटी लगी है $1
फर्स्ट बाउंट और $200 की। इससे बड़ी खुशी
की बात मेरे लिए नहीं हो सकती है। एंड
बहुत सारे अभी लर्नर्स के बंटीज जब लग रहे
हैं आज के टाइम में तो मुझे अच्छा लगता है
कि चलो बग बंटी की जो क्लासेस हुई हमारी
वो सक्सेसफुल रही हैं। बहुत सारी
अच्छी-अच्छी मुझे आते हैं मैसेज आते हैं।
एंड मेरे पास जो बग बंटी वाले हैं वह
मैसेज करते हैं कि सर मुझे यह मुझे वह ऐसे
वैसे करते हैं। बातें करते हैं। तो मुझे
इससे इससे बहुत खुशी मिलती है। बहुत
ज़्यादा खुशी मिलती है। दैट्स ग्रेट
सिद्धार्थ। बहुत अच्छा लगा। आपने आपने टैग
किया है क्या सिद्धार्थ डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। देख लेते हैं। सिद्धार्थ ने अगर टैग
किया है तो लाइव आपको मैं दिखा देता हूं
कि ऐसा नहीं है कि यह कोई फर्जी बात है।
सिद्धार्थ आपने टैग किया है। तो एक बार
बताइए।
लेट्स सी इफ सिद्धार्थ हैज़ टैग्ड अस
सोहिल सिद्धार्थ हां जी सिद्धार्थ ने हमें
टैग किया है। ओके एक्साइटेड टू शेयर अ
स्मॉल माइलस्टोन इन माय साइबर सिक्योरिटी
जर्नी। आई हैव रिसीव्ड माय फर्स्ट
प्राइवेट बग बाउंड्री प्रोग्राम इनविटेशन
ऑन बग बेस। ठीक है? दिस अपोरर्चुनिटी
रिफ्लेक्स द लर्निंग एंड प्रैक्टिकल आई
हैव बीन बिल्डिंग आवर्स लाइक। ठीक है?
स्पेशल थैंक्स टू निद। ठीक है? फॉर देयर
गाइडेंस एंड लुकिंग फॉरवर्ड। क्या बात है?
अ अ ओके
क्या बात है इस पे आपको $200 की बाउंट्री
लगी है। बहुत अच्छा सिद्धार्थ अच्छा लगा।
आपको एक प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम पे बाउंटी लगी
है। प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम पे आपने बाउंट
अर्न किया है। दैट्स दैट्स ग्रेट फॉर यू
एंड कांग्रेचुलेशंस
टू यू। ठीक है? बहुत-बहुत कांग्रेचुलेशंस
आपको। अच्छा लगा यार।
चलिए सर Lindin पर जॉब जॉब पर बोथ लोग जॉब
इंटर्नशिप हां हां यार हां करते हैं करते
हैं जॉब इंटर्नशिप सब में आपको मिलती है।
ठीक है तो ये टाइप्स ऑफ़ वीpए आपको समझ में
अब आ चुका होगा। अब यहां
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पे कुछ
सस्पिशियस इंडिकेटर ये एक ये जो है ना
इसको मैं हटा देता हूं। इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं थी। ओके।
नेक्स्ट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आते
हैं यहां पे कि वीपीए के लिए सस्िशियस
इंडिकेटर्स क्या हो सकते हैं? लाइक व्हाट
कुड बी द सस्िशियस इंडिकेटर्स फॉर द
वीपीएस राइट एंड
प्रज्वल थैंक यू नितेश सर। मैंने आज ही
डीसीसीआई कोर्स ले लिया। क्या बात है
प्रज्वल योर वेलकम अच्छा लगा।
बहुत अच्छे। ओके। ठीक है।
दो साल हो गए हैं।
ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
सस्िशियस इंडिकेटर्स अगर वर्चुअल प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क के केस में हम बात करें इन केस ऑफ़
वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क तो सस्िशियस
इंडिकेटर्स क्या हो सकते हैं? जो सस्िशियस
होंगे? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लॉग
इन फ्रॉम अनयूजुअल कंट्री। कोई अनयूजुअल
कंट्री से लॉग इन हो रही है। यह एक सस्िश
सस्पिशन क्रिएट करेगा। मल्टीपल लॉगिन्स
सेम यूजर है बट डिफरेंट लोकेशन से अगर लॉग
इन हो रहा है। वो भी एक मल्टीपल लॉगिन्स
भी है। वो भी सस्पिशियस इंडिकेटर्स में
आपके आएंगे। वीpए यूज़्ड प्लस सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी आफ्टर लॉग इन। वीpए यूज़ हुआ है
बट लॉग इन के बाद आफ्टर उसके बाद एक
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी कुछ हुई है। बहुत डाटा
ज्यादा ट्रांसफर किया जा रहा है वीpए के
थ्रू। मतलब हाई डाटा ट्रांसफर थ्रू वीpए
यह एक किया जा रहा है। तो ये सस्पेशियस
इंडिकेटर्स हैं जो आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिल सकते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कॉमन वीपीए
अब्यूज़ क्या होता है? अटैकर्स यूज़ वीpए टू
हाइड आइडेंटिटी बायपास Jio रेस्ट्रिकशंस
एक्सेस इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स। तो ये वीpए को
यूज़ में करके अटैकर जो हैं इसको यूज़ करते
हैं आइडेंटिटी हाइड करने के लिए। Jio
रेस्ट्रिकशंस को यानी Jio मतलब जो
जियोफिकल रेस्ट्रिकशंस जो होते हैं कि
भैया यहां का यहां बैन होगा। यहां का यह
नहीं अलाउड होगा। यह वेब एप्लीकेशन उस
रीजन में अलाउड नहीं है। उसको बाईपास करने
के लिए और इंटरनल नेटवर्क्स को बाईपास
करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। दैट्स
इट। ठीक है? आई होप समझ में आया होगा। एसओ
से एग्जांपल आप देख लो। एक यूजर है एडमिन
लॉग इन IPपी है जर्मनी। वीpए IPपी है
इंडिया। गैप टाइम है 2 मिनट। अब सोचो वीpए
IP जो है वो इंडिया की है। लॉग इन कर रहा
है बंदा जर्मनी से। तो यार ये कैसे हो
सकता है? ये कि 2 मिनट में वो जर्मनी से
इंडिया। इंडिया से जर्मनी मान लो ट्रेवल
कर चुका हो। ऐसा तो पॉसिबल ही नहीं है।
इंपॉसिबल है। इंपॉसिबल ट्राइवल हिस्ट्री आ
गई है। तो यह एक कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड अकाउंट का
एसओसी अह आउटकम है। तो यहां पे यह एक
एग्जांपल के थ्रू आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
कि बेसिकली कुछ इस तरीके के आपको जब
दिखेंगे लॉग्स में यानी कि अह डैशबोर्ड
में तो आपको समझ जाना है बेसिकली कि हां
ये किस तरह का है। इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल ऐसा
ट्रेवल हो नहीं सकता। 2 मिनट में जर्मनी
से इंडिया। तो यहां
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है अकाउंट। दैट्स इट।
बिल्कुल। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पर आते हैं फायर वाल के ऊपर में।
ठीक है? वी आर नाउ गोइंग टू द फायर वाल
सेक्शन। फायरवल क्या होता है? देखो
फायर वाल के बारे में मैं सिंपल सा यहां
पे फंडा बताता हूं। कंट्रोल्स ट्रैफिक
बेस्ड रूल्स बेस्ड ऑन रूल्स। कंट्रोल्स
ट्रैफिक बेस्ड ऑन रूल्स। एक ट्रैफिक होती
है इसकी। मतलब कि जैसे आपका जैसे आप
नेटवर्क में क्या होता है इंटरनल आपका होम
नेटवर्क है बाहर का इंटरनेट है तो बाहर के
इंटरनेट से आपके नेटवर्क पे एक डेटा पैकेट
फ्लो होगा और आपके नेटवर्क से बाहर के तरफ
एक डेटा पैकेट फ्लो होगा। राइट? एक पैकेट
फ्लो अंदर से बाहर जाएगा। एक बाहर से अंदर
की तरफ फ्लो होगा। यही फ्लो होता है
नॉर्मली हर कम्युनिकेशन में। उसी फ्लो में
उसी ट्रैफिक को कंट्रोल करने के लिए कुछ
स्पेसिफिक रूल्स के ऊपर जो काम करे डिवाइस
या जो टेक्नोलॉजी वो फायरवल कहलाता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? तो फायरवल एक ऐसी डिवाइस आप बोल
सकते हो या एक ऐसी टेक्नोलॉजी बोल सकते
हो। एक ऐसा सॉफ्टवेयर बोल सकते हो क्योंकि
frewl एक हार्डवेयर भी होते हैं,
सॉफ्टवेयर फायरव्स भी होते हैं। तो मैं
दोनों को मिक्स करके यहां पे बोल रहा हूं।
तो हार्डवेयर फायरल की बात करें या
सॉफ्टवेयर यह एक सर्टेन रूल्स पे काम करते
हैं। एक रूल मेड है बनाया हुआ है और उसी
रूल के बेसिस पे यह क्या करते हैं? उस
ट्रैफिक को कंट्रोल करते हैं कि भाई कौन
सी ट्रैफिक को अंदर से बाहर जाने देना है।
कौन सी ट्रैफिक को बाहर से अंदर आने देना
है। किस ट्रैफिक को ब्लॉक करना है। किस
ट्रैफिक को वहीं पे ड्रॉप कर देना है। किस
ट्रैफिक को बिल्कुल अलाउ नहीं करना है। ये
सब काम करते हैं हमारे फायर वाल। और इसमें
इसी को हम अलाउ डिनाई ट्रैफिक बोलते हैं।
या तो यह अलाउ करेंगे या डिनाई करते हैं।
भैया या तो आप अलाउड हो या तो आप डिनाइड
हो। ऐसा कुछ होता है। अब फायरवल के भी
क्या होते हैं? बहुत सारे टाइप्स होते
हैं। देखो ये मैंने कुछ टाइप्स नेटवर्क
फायरवल, होस्ट फायरवल, स्टेटफुल फायरवल
लिखा है। वैसे फायरवल के मल्टीपल टाइप्स
होते हैं। बहुत टाइप्स होते हैं। हमें
टाइप्स में जाके घुस के उनकी वर्किंग नहीं
पढ़नी है ना हमको समझनी है। हमें समझना है
फायरवल क्या होता है? कैसे काम करता है।
दैट्स इट। [खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बिल्कुल। अब इसी इंटरनल एंड एक्सटर्नल
ट्रैफिक जो होती है जो एक इंटरनल ट्रैफिक
जो होती है एक अंदर की तरफ जो ट्रैफिक आती
है और एक होती है बाहर की ट्रैफिक जो
ट्रैफिक जाती है इसको हम बोलते हैं
इनबाउंड एंड आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक। जैसे कि
अगर बाहर की तरफ आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक का मतलब
है बाहर जाने वाली ट्रैफिक। जो बाहर की
तरफ हो के जा रही है। इनबाउंड का मतलब है
जो इंटरनल आने वाली जो ट्रैफिक है उसकी
बात हो रही है। तो ये इनबाउंड और आउटबाउंड
ट्रैफिक कहलाती है। अब देखो अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
मैंने एक्शन बताया अलाउ डिनाई का। तो यहां
पे क्या है? तीन तरह की चीजें मैं आपको
दिखा रहा हूं। एक एक्शन होगा एक्सेप्ट का,
एक एक्शन होगा डिनाई का, एक एक्शन होगा
रिजेक्ट का। ठीक है? ये तीन चीज़ होती है।
तीनों में क्या डिफरेंस है? मैं आपको
समझाता हूं। जैसे एक इनकमिंग पैकेट है, एक
फायरवल लगा हुआ है और यहां पे अंदर में
आपका नेटवर्क है आपका। तो क्या होता है?
यहां पे अगर एक्सेप्ट हो रहा है तो क्या
होगा? पैकेट पाससेस थ्रू द फायर वाल।
पैकेट परमिटेड पैकेट पाससेस थ्रू द फायर
वाल। दूसरा यहां पे होगा कि इनकमिंग पैकेट
आएगी। फायर लगा है। यहां पे अगर डिनाई कर
दिया जा रहा है तो पैकेट इज़ ड्रॉप। पैकेट
वहीं पे ड्रॉप कर दिया जाएगा। यानी
एक्सेप्ट हुआ तो पैकेट फायर वाल से पास हो
जाएगी। एक्सेप्ट का अगर रूल है वो उसको
फॉलो करता है। तो अगर वो पैकेट एक्सेप्ट
का रूल फॉलो नहीं करता है तो डिनाई अगर हो
जा रहा है तो पैकेट को ड्रॉप कर दिया जाता
है वहीं पे। बट यहां पे है एक रिजेक्ट
रिजेक्ट का। अब क्या होता है? जैसे
इनकमिंग पैकेट आ रही है, फार लगा है और
अगर रिजेक्ट हो रही है तो इन केस में क्या
होगा? पैकेट इज़ ब्लॉक्ड। पैकेट को ब्लॉक
कर दिया जाता है। एंड आईसीएमपी मैसेज
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिवली प्रोहिबिटेड और टीसीपी
आरएसटी पैकेट इज़ सेंट बैक टू सेंडर। कुछ
ऐसा कुछ करके एक एक मतलब वियर्ड मैसेज वो
भेज दिया जाता है क्लाइंट को कि भैया
एक्सेस इज़ डिनाइड। मतलब कि आपने जो पैकेट
आपने जो यहां पे एक्शन किया आपने जो पैकेट
भेजा था वो पैकेट जो ठीक है आई हमारे पास
हमने क्या किया उसको पैकेट को रिजेक्ट कर
दिया ब्लॉक कर दिया हमने उसको पूरा
कंप्लीटली डिनाई नहीं करा हमने उसको
रिजेक्ट करा है किसी एक रूल के बेसिस पे
कि भैया ऐसा कुछ रूल है कि हम इसको ना तो
एक्सेप्ट कर सकते हैं ना हम टोटली डिनाई
कर रहे हैं बट हम इसको रिजेक्ट कर रहे
हैं। हम यहां पे क्या बोल रहे हैं कि आपका
जो एक्सेस आप करने की कोशिश कर रहे थे वो
हमने डिनाई किया है सर्वर के साइड से कि
हम किसी आपने या तो कुछ गलत एक्सेस करने
की कोशिश करी है या आपने प्रॉपर जो है वो
आपने ऑप्शंस या प्रॉपर जो आर्गुमेंट्स हैं
वो नहीं दिए हैं। प्रॉपर एक पाथ जो जिस
तरीके से एक्सेस करना चाहिए उस तरीके से
एक्सेस नहीं किया आपने तो हमने उसको डिनाई
किया। तो ये जो चीजें हैं होती है मेनली
जो होती है अलाउ डिनाई होती है मेन आपका
अलाउ और डिनाई होता है बट इस केस में कई
बार ऐसा होता है रिजेक्शन केस में एक्सेस
डिनाई के केस में ये पॉसिबल है ये होता है
आपका फायरवल फायरवॉल कुछ इसी तरीके से अब
इसमें और भी चीजें हैं उसको भी हम समझेंगे
हां फ़्टर्ड बोल सकते हो उसको बिल्कुल सही
बात है इसको आप फ़्टर्ड भी बोल सकते हो जो
रिजेक्ट है एक्स फ़िल्टर्ड यू कैन से
फ़िल्टर्ड ऐसा रिजेक्ट एक्सेस डिनाइड बट अह
मेन जो है आपका अलाउड डिनाई दो चीज़ें आपकी
होती है जिस पे ये काम करता है। ठीक है?
अब देखो, अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे फायरवल को थोड़ा ग्राफिकली हम
समझते हैं। फायरवल किस तरीके के होते हैं?
देखो, यहां पे जब मैं Windows के फायर वॉल
पे चलूंगा, पहले इस पे आने के पहले मैं
Windows Frew पे चलता हूं। पहले मैं यहां
कंट्रोल पैनल ओपन करता हूं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
और मैं यहां पे चलता हूं। Windows डिफेंडर
फायर। ये Windows डिफेंडर फायर है।
हालांकि हमें Windows का मेन फायरल चाहिए
था। बट हम इसको ही ओपन करेंगे क्योंकि इसी
में मर्ज हो चुका है। यह पहले यह Windows
fir करता था ओनली। तो Windows Frew पे जब
हम जाएंगे तो यहां पे देखो तुम्हें यहां
पे एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा।
अलऊ एन ऐप और फीचर थ्रू Windows डिफेंडर
फायर वाल। अब मैं इस पर क्लिक करता हूं।
अब इस पे जब मैं क्लिक करूंगा ना तो यहां
पे आपको एक लिस्ट मिलेगी जिसमें क्या
होगा? अलऊ एप्स टू कम्युनिकेट थ्रू
Windows डिफेंडर फायर। यहां पे एप्स की
सारी लिस्ट होंगी और इनमें इनमें क्या
होगा कि अलऊ एंड डिनाई का ऑप्शन होगा। अब
एक प्राइवेट नेटवर्क है, एक पब्लिक
नेटवर्क है। तो ये जो नेटवर्क्स है ये तो
आपकी अपनी नेटवर्क जो भी आपने प्राइवेट या
पब्लिक नाम रखा है। तो जैसे मैंने अभी
पब्लिक का रखा हुआ है। पब्लिक यूज़ कर रहा
हूं मैं। तो पब्लिक के ऊपर में हम देखेंगे
तो यहां पे अलाउ डिनाई है। तो जैसे इसको
आप अनटिक कर दोगे तो ये डिनाई हो जाएगा।
टिक कर दोगे तो अलाउ हो जाएगा। तो ये
प्राइवेट के लिए पहला कॉलम है। दूसरे
पब्लिक नेटवर्क के लिए। तो जो भी आपका
नेटवर्क हो उसके अगेंस्ट आप कर सकते हैं।
तो यहां पे अब क्या हो सकती है कि जैसे
मान लो कि मेरे पास यहां पे मैं कोई एक ऐप
ले लेता हूं। जैसे यह देखो रिमोट
असिस्टेंस है। ठीक है? रिमोट असिस्टेंस
वाली फीचर है यहां पे। अब ये फीचर
प्राइवेट नेटवर्क में तो अलाउड है बट
पब्लिक नेटवर्क में ये डिनाइड है। तो अगर
मैं रिमोट असिस्टेंस वाली फीचर को यूज़
करना चाहूंगा तो ये फारवल ब्लॉक कर देगा
मेरे उस
उस चाहने को मेरे उस एग्जीक्यूशन को
बोलेगा कि भैया ये तो पॉसिबल नहीं है
क्योंकि आपने तो यहां पे फायरवल का जो रूल
है वो लगा के रखा है। क्या रूल लगा के रखा
है भैया? वो लगा के रखा है कि भैया मैं तो
डिनाई करूंगा। जो भी रिमोट असिस्टेंस होगी
उसको मैं डिनाई करूंगा। बस यही चीज है। तो
जहां से जो चीजें फायर वाल जो चीजें अलाउ
होगी उसको अलाउ किया जाएगा। जो चीजें
डिनाई होगी उसको डिनाई किया जाएगा। जो भी
प्रोसेस होती है जो भी प्रोसेस के लिए जो
भी एप्स या फीचर्स होंगे जो अलाउड अलाउड
होंगे अलाउड डिनाई। अब यहां पे चेंज
सेटिंग करोगे तो यहां पे अलाउ अनदर ऐप
करके मैनुअली आप अलाउ कर सकते हो किसी ऐप
को। मैनुअली अगर आपको कोई ऐप अलाउ करना है
किसी को पब्लिक नेटवर्क या प्राइवेट
नेटवर्क में तो आप अलऊ कर सकते हो। ठीक
है? यहां डिटेल्स पे आप जाओगे तो यहां पे
इसकी डिटेल वगैरह बता देता है। ठीक है? अब
ये देखो अब यहां पे जैसे मतलब डिटेल में
मतलब उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम की कि दिस
फीचर अलाउज़ यूज़र्स ऑफ़ दिस कंप्यूटर टू
रिक्वेस्ट रिमोट असिस्टेंस फ्रॉम अदर
यूज़र्स ऑन द नेटवर्क लाइक यूज़ यू यूपीएपी
हो गया एसएसडीपी ये सब मतलब कुछ
प्रोटोकॉल्स को यूज़ करके। तो ये होती है।
अब यहां पे आते हैं Windows फायर वॉल के
ऊपर में।
अब यहां पे हम एडवांस सेटिंग्स पे आते
हैं। जब हम एडवांस सेटिंग्स पे आएंगे तो
यहां पे आपको एक एडवांस सेटिंग देखने को
मिलेगी और यहां पे आपको चीजें मिलेंगी दो
इनबाउंड रूल्स एंड आउटबाउंड रूल्स। अब
देखो ये इनबाउंड रूल्स जो है राइट क्लिक
मैं करता हूं यहां पे एंड यहां पे हेल्प
पे क्लिक करता हूं। तो देखो क्या होता है
यहां पे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एक मिनट लिस्ट एक बार देख लूं। इसमें कुछ
है क्या आपके लिए?
आउटबाउंड में शायद मैंने क्रिएट करी होगी
या नहीं करी है पता नहीं।
नहीं अभी तो नहीं क्रिएटेड है। वैसे मैं
क्रिएट करके कभी-कभी पहले रखता था। देखो
यहां पे मैं आपको पहले डिफरेंस समझाता
हूं। इनबाउंड कनेक्शंस एंड आउटबाउंड
कनेक्शंस में यहां पे मैं आपको बताता हूं।
ठीक है? इनबाउंड कनेक्शंस में जो भी
इनकमिंग कनेक्शंस के लिए हैं रूल्स वो
यहां पे डिफाइंड है। अलग-अलग जैसे अ आपके
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हैं एंड उनके अ
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हैं और उनको अलऊ किया गया है
या डिनाई किया गया है वो सारी चीजें यहां
पे बताई। जैसे मान लो कि यहां पे
कोई भी एक एप्लीकेशन ले लेते हैं। नोन
एप्लीकेशन लेते हैं।
हम हम हम
हां देखो मान लो ये Windows कैमरा है। ठीक
है? ये Windows कैमरा है। एक एप्लीकेशन है
Windows कैमरा। अब अगर मैं Windows कैमरा
इस पर्टिकुलर यह Windows कैमरा है। अब मैं
इस Windows कैमरा को क्या करता हूं कि
यहां पे जब मैं इसको चेक करूंगा ये
इनबाउंड रूल्स के लिए बनी हुई है। तो मैं
यहां देखूंगा कि ये ग्रुप Windows कैमरा
से बिलोंग करता है। डोमेन ठीक है यहां पे।
इनेबल्ड है यहां पे। यस इनेबल्ड है। एक्शन
में क्या है? अलाउड है। यहां पे ओवराइड नो
है। प्रोग्राम एनी कैटेगरीज़ से है। लोकल
एड्रेस है। ये सारी चीज़। अब मैं राइट
क्लिक करूंगा। और यहां पे जब इस रूल पे
डिसेबल रूल का ऑप्शन आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। अब जब इस रूल को डिसेबल कर दोगे
तो ये रूल डिसेबल हो जाएगी। ये रूल अह नॉट
ऑपरेटिव हो जाएगी। किसी काम की नहीं रह
जाएगी। अब मैं यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज पे
क्लिक करूंगा। प्रॉपर्टीज पे क्लिक करूंगा
तो देखो यहां पे क्या आ रहा है यहां पे?
दिस इज़ अ प्रीडफाइंड रूल एंड सम ऑफ़ इट्स
प्रॉपर्टीज़ कैन नॉट बी मॉडिफाइड। क्योंकि
ये Windows की तरफ से प्रीडफाइंड रूल है।
तो कुछ प्रॉपर्टीज़ नहीं चेंज होंगी। बाकी
हम चेंज कर सकते हैं। तो मैं यहां पे जनरल
पे आया। तो अब यहां पे आप देख सकते हो यह
इनेबल्ड है। उसके बाद यहां पे एक्शन में
क्या आ रहा है यहां पे? अलऊ द कनेक्शन।
मतलब इसके लिए हमें अलऊ करना है फायरवॉल
को। अलाउ द कनेक्शन इफ इट इज़ सिक्योर। अगर
दूसरा ऑप्शन है अलाउ करो। अगर ये सिक्योर
है। इसको कस्टमाइज करके आप यहां पे ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट कर सकते हो कि अलाउ द कनेक्शन इफ
इट इज़ ऑथेंटिकेटेड एंड इंटीग्रिटी
प्रोटेक्टेड। मतलब इसको तभी अलाउ करो जब
ये ऑथेंटिकेटेड हो और इंटीग्रिटी वायलेशन
ना हुआ हो। अलाउ द कनेक्शन टू बी
इंक्रिप्टेड। ये सारे ऑप्शंस हैं जिसको आप
सेलेक्ट कर सकते हो। या तो सीधा सिंपल
अलाउ कर दो। या तो सीधा है ब्लॉक कर दो।
मतलब इसको कंप्लीटली ब्लॉक ही कर दो। तो
रूल्स को ऐसे आप अलऊ डिनाई कर सकते हैं।
अलाउ या ब्लॉक कर सकते हैं जो भी रूल्स
बने या खुद का रूल भी आप क्रिएट कर सकते
हैं। उसी तरीके से यहां पे आउटबाउंड
कनेक्शन ये आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक्स के लिए ये
रूल्स बने हुए हैं। जो ये बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट कुछ
रूल्स बने हैं यहां पे। अब जैसे मान लो
देखो अब इसमें आउटगोइंग मैं इसको आपको ऐसे
समझाता हूं। जैसे आपने ना आप अभी भी शायद
यूज़ करते होंगे। क्रैक्ड सॉफ्टवेयर्स आप
लोग में से कई लोग यूज़ करते होंगे। राइट?
आप लोग में से कई लोग जो है वो क्रैक्ड
सॉफ्टवेयर्स यूज़ करते होंगे। अब क्रैक्ड
सॉफ्टवेयर्स में एक्टिवेशन के टाइम में
जैसे बहुत सारे वीडियो एडिटर्स होते हैं,
बहुत सारे सॉफ्टवेयर्स होते हैं। जब आप
उसको क्रैक्ड में एक्टिवेट करने जाओगे तो
वह उसमें इंस्ट्रक्शंस दिया रहता है कि आप
फायरवल में उसको डिनाई कर दो। एक उसका कोई
फाइल होता है exc फाइल होता है या कोई भी
फाइल होती है उसको फायरवॉल में जो है उसको
डिनाई कर दो। ऐसा होता है। ऐसा कई बार लोग
वहां पे लिखा होता है उसके डिस्क्रिप्शन
में। तो उनमें आउट बाउंड रूल्स में ही
आपको डिनाई करना होता है। इनबाउंड रूल्स
में डिनाई नहीं करना है। उसका कोई मतलब
नहीं बनता है। इनबाउंड मतलब आने वाली
ट्रैफिक है। आउटबाइंड मतलब कि जब आप उस
एप्लीकेशन को यूज़ करने जा रहे हो,
एग्जीक्यूट करने जा रहे हो तो वो आप कि
फायरवल उसको ब्लॉक कर दे उसके इंटरनेट
कनेक्टिविटी को उसके सर्वर से। मतलब कि वो
एप्लीकेशन अपने सर्वर से मेन सर्वर से
इंटरनेट के थ्रू कनेक्ट ना हो जाए। सो दैट
कि आपकी जो क्रैक इनेशन है वो वहां तक ना
पहुंचे और आपका सर्वर जो आपका जो
एप्लीकेशन है वो डीएक्टिवेट ना हो जाए।
यानी कि उसकी जो बेसिकली क्रैक्ड
फंक्शनैलिटी है वो ख़ ना हो जाए वो फिर वो
जेन्युइन सॉफ्टवेयर ना बन जाए ऐसा ना हो
जाए या डिटेक्शन ना आ जाए ऐसा है तो उसी
में जैसे आउटबाउंड रूल है तो अगर आपको
न्यू जैसे उस वह कैसे क्रिएट होती थी न्यू
रूल कैसे क्रिएट हो सकती है न्यू रूल पे
क्लिक करोगे यहां पे न्यू रूल आ जाएगा अब
किसको आपको किस चीज के लिए रूल बनानी है
प्रोग्राम के लिए बनानी है पोर्ट के लिए
बनानी है कोई प्रीडफाइन हुआ है या कस्टम
रूल तो मुझे मान लो कोई एक प्रोग्राम के
लिए बनानी है तो मैंने प्रोग्राम सेलेक्ट
किया अब नेक्स्ट करूंगा अब नेक्स्ट के लिए
ऑल प्रोग्राम्स या प्रोग्राम का पाथ दे दो
तो अब वो पाथ देना है जहां पे उसकी फाइल
पड़ी है तो तो मैं जैसे सी ड्राइव में
प्रोग्राम फाइल्स में चलता हूं। कोई भी एक
प्रोग्राम ले लेते हैं। अभी मैं इसको इसको
हम फाइनल नहीं करेंगे। बस अब मैं आपको
दिखा रहा हूं। तो मान लो कि मैं वीडियो
लाइन पे करके vएलc पे करके
एंड यहां पे vlc पे आके मैं मान लो
vlc.exc जो है इसको सेलेक्ट कर लेता हूं।
ठीक है? इसको मान लो मैं आउटबन ट्रैफिक
इसका जो है बंद करना है। तो मैंने इसको
सेलेक्ट किया। यहां पे ओपन कर लिया। अब ये
vlc.exec का जो है वो एक आउटबाउंड रूल
क्रिएट होगा जो आप अभी आगे क्रिएट होगा कि
क्या करना है इसको। अब मैं इसको नेक्स्ट
करता हूं। अब मैं नेक्स्ट जब करूंगा तो
यहां पे अब ऑप्शन आएगा अलऊ करना है। अलाऊ
करना है जब सिक्योर हो या ब्लॉक करना है।
तो मान लो मुझे ब्लॉक करनी है इसको तो मैं
ब्लॉक करके यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक
करूंगा। अब किस में अप्लाई करना है इस रूल
को? डोमेन में या प्राइवेट नेटवर्क में या
पब्लिक नेटवर्क में। ठीक है? तो अगर मान
लो आपका आपका कंप्यूटर किसी कॉर्पोरेट
डोमेन से कनेक्टेड है तो उसको सेलेक्ट
कीजिए। मेरा नहीं है तो उसको हटा दो।
प्राइवेट नेटवर्क जैसे आपका कनेक्टेड एक
प्राइवेट नेटवर्क लोकेशन से कनेक्टेड है
तो उसमें कर लो। मेरा पब्लिक नेटवर्क
ऑब्वियसली यूज़ हो रहा है। तो मैं पब्लिक
मान लो यूज़ करके सेलेक्ट करके रखने देता
हूं। यहां पे नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करूंगा। अब
इसका आप नाम दे दो। तो मैं कर दूंगा
वीएलसी अ
आउटबाउंड
रूल। ये मैंने डाल दिया। डिस्क्रिप्शन में
कुछ भी डाल दो। यहां पे फिनिश कर दो। अब
यहां पे फिनिश जब कर दोगे तो ये यहां पे
क्या होगा? कनेक्शन ये बन गई है। अब यहां
पे फिर से जाएंगे ना हम यहां पे एडवांस
सेटिंग्स पे और आउटबाउंड कनेक्शंस पे तो
आपको यहां पे देखने को मिलेगा वीएलसी
आउटबाउंड रूल और यहां पे देखो यहां पे ये
इस तरह का कुछ सिंबल दिया हुआ है। यहां पे
ब्लॉक है। एक्शन जो है ब्लॉक है। तो मैं
क्या करूंगा? वीएलसी ओपन करता हूं। ये
वीएलसी मैंने ओपन किया। ये ओपन हो के आ
गया यहां पे। अब यही वीएलसी जैसे है। मान
लो मैं चेक फॉर अपडेट्स करता हूं यहां पे।
अब मैं चेक फॉर अपडेट्स करूंगा। तो ये
क्या आ रहा है? एन एरर अकर्ड व्हाइल
चेकिंग फॉर अपडेट्स। देख रहे हो? तो
फायरवॉल की
स्ट्रेंथ फायर वाल का पावर फायरवल से हमने
आउटबाउट कनेक्शन vएलc.exc का ब्लॉक कर
दिया। तो अब मैं यहां पे आ रहा हूं ना तो
अब आ रहा है एरर। मैं रिचेक कर रहा हूं
फिर भी एरर आएगा। ये अपडेट हो ही नहीं
सकती है क्योंकि ये vएलc के सर्वर से अब
कनेक्ट ही नहीं हो पा रही है हमारा।
हां हमारी रिक्वेस्ट जो आउटबाउंड जो हम
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं वीएलसी सर्वर से वो
हमारी रिक्वेस्ट ही नहीं जा रही है।
क्योंकि हमने आउटबाउंड रूल में ये डिफाइन
कर दिया है कि भैया इसको ब्लॉक कर दो। तो
अब हम कितना भी रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे अब इसका
इंटरनेट से कोई लेना देना नहीं ये
सॉफ्टवेयर का है। इंटरनेट का वाला कोई भी
काम आप करोगे ना जो बाहर इसके सर्वर से
कनेक्ट करता होगा वो नहीं हो पाएगा। सिंपल
सा हां नॉइज़ आ रहा है क्योंकि पीछे कुछ
डमरूडू डमडू बज रही है। कुछ हो रहा है।
कुछ इवेंट फंक्शन होगा उसकी उसकी ऑडियो आ
रही होगी। ठीक है? तो ये कुछ इस तरीके से
काम करता है। ये तो आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा।
हां। सोसाइटी में कुछ होगी कुछ बारात टाइप
का। उसी का आपको आ रहा होगा आवाज।
तो यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अब अब मैं
यहां पे रिचेक कर रहा हूं। देखो मैं यहां
पे मल्टीपल रिचेक कर रहा हूं। ये एन एरर
एन एरर ऐसे ही आ रहा है। ठीक है? अब मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं? मैं फिर से फायर वाले
वाले में जा रहा हूं। ये जो वीए वीएलसी
आउटबाउंड रूल है इसको मैं डिलीट कर देता
हूं। मान लो इसको मैं डिसेबल कर। चलो इसको
डिसेबल कर देता हूं। फिलहाल डिसेबल कर
दिया वीएलसी वाले को। अब मैं वीएलसी ओपन
कर रहा हूं फिर से। एंड मैं अब यहां पे
वीएलसी पे
रिचेक कर रहा हूं। देखो अब यह रिचेक करके
और यहां आ गया न्यू वर्जन ऑफ द
वीएलसी अवेलेबल। यह आपको दिख रहा। अब अब
आपको समझ में आ गया कि यहां पे अब यहां पे
आ रहा है ये न्यू वर्जन अवेलेबल। अब ये
न्यू वर्जन यहां पे यहां पे इसने अपडेट भी
कर दिया। वो भी कर दिया और यह न्यू वर्जन
चेक भी कर पा रहा है। राइट? तो कुछ इस
तरीके से होती है। आप चाहें तो फिर अब इस
पर्टिकुलर वीएलसी आउटबर्न रूल को राइट
क्लिक करेंगे एंड यहां पे डिलीट कर देंगे।
तो यह वीएलसी आउटबोर्ड डिलीट हो जाएगी और
वापस से यह फिर भी काम करेगी। चेक फॉर
अपडेट्स करेंगे यहां पे अगेन यहां पे
अपडेट करके। तो ये आपको समझ में आ गया? आर
यू गेटिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग? तो ये
इनबाउंड और आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन होती है फायर
वाल के आउटबाउंड।
डीड यू गेट गाइज़ अंडरस्टुड?
ओके। सभी को समझ में आ गया? बता दीजिए एक
बार। फटाफट बताइए। इफ एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
देन ओनली वी विल अगेन प्रोसीड
गाइस रिप्लाई प्लीज आप लोग एक बार कमेंट
रिप्लाई तो करो यार बताओ तो सही कि समझ
में आया या नहीं यार बहुत कम लोग रिप्लाई
करते हैं
क्लियर है तो देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो अब फायरवल को मैं एक ग्राफिकल डेम
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के थ्रू समझा रहा हूं। अभी
आपने देखा इंटरनल नेटवर्क होता है और एक
बाहर का नेटवर्क होता है।
बीच [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] में फायर
वाल लगे होते हैं। ये ये आपने देखा एक
इंटरनल नेटवर्क एक बाहर का नेटवर्क। देखो
लेकिन
फायरवॉल कुछ इस तरीके से होता है। एक आपका
इंटरनल नेटवर्क होता है। एक आपका बाहर का
इंटरनेट होता है। इंटरनल नेटवर्क के बाद
आपका इंटरनल फायर वाल एक काम करता है।
उसके बाद यहां पे एक एक्सटर्नल फायर वाल
होता है जो एक्सटर्नल इंटरनेट के साथ काम
करता है। और बीच में एक एरिया होती है
जिसको हम बोलते हैं डीएमजी।
डीएम बोल लो या डीएमजी बोल दो जिसको हम
डीमिलिटराइज्ड जोन बोलते हैं। ठीक है?
इसको हम बोलते हैं डीमिलिटराइज जोन। यह एक
पेरीमीटर होता है जो कि इंटरनल फेयरवल और
एक्सटर्नल फेयरवल के बीच में होती है।
इसका मतलब यह हुआ मैं आपको यहां पे बता
देता हूं।
आपको ज्यादा [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
समझ में आएगा।
देखो
जनरली क्या होता है? जनरली आपने क्या देखा
कि क्या होता है? जनरली क्या होता है?
यहां पे यह एक कंप्यूटर है।
ठीक है? यह बाहर का इंटरनेट हो गया।
और यहां पे बीच में एक फायर वाल हो गई।
बीच में क्या हो गया? यह फायर वाल हो गई।
ठीक है?
कुछ इस तरीके से। बट एक्चुअल में होता
क्या है? देखो एक्चुअल में क्या होता है?
एक्चुअल में कुछ इस तरीके से होता है कि
यहां पे आपका यह एक नेटवर्क हो गया।
नेटवर्क इसको हम बोल देंगे ऐसे। इसको बोल
देंगे इंटरनल नेटवर्क।
ठीक है? फिर यहां पर एक
इंटरनल फायरवल होती है IF
फिर यह एरिया एक आपका खाली एरिया मान लो
यहां पे फिर आपका एक्सटर्नल फायरवल होता
है EF
और फिर यहां पे आपकी होती है
इंटरनेट
इंटरनेट या बाहर की जो नेटवर्क होती है वह
होती है और इसी एरिया को हम बोलते हैं
डीएमजी डीमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन। इसको हम बोलते
हैं डीएमजी
डीमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन। ठीक है? यह एक पूरा
प्रॉपर परफेक्ट एग्जांपल हो गया आपके
फायरवल सेटअप का। कुछ इसी तरीके से यह
प्रॉपर जो है सेटअप आपकी होती है
यह वाली।
इस तरीके से यह काम करता है। तो आपका जो
इंटरनल नेटवर्क है उसको प्रोटेक्ट करने के
लिए इंटरनल फायरवल होता है। बाहर की जो भी
प्रैक्टिस आती है उसके लिए। फिर डीएमजी
होता है। डिमिलिटराइज जोन होता है एक
पेरीमीटर एक एक जैसे होता है ना आप समझ लो
कि जैसे बॉर्डर अब जैसे एक इंडिया का
बॉर्डर हो गया। मान लो एक पाकिस्तान का
बॉर्डर हो गया। बीच में एक बफर पॉइंट होता
है ना बीच में एक खाली जगह होती है। राइट?
जो बेसिकली जिसको हम बोलते हैं जिसको हम
बोलते हैं क्या बोलते हैं उसको? खाली जो
जगह होती है एक बफर ज़ोन जो होती है उसी
तरीके का यह डीएमजी होता है। तो कुछ इस
तरीके से आपका फायरवल ऑपरेट करता है। कुछ
इस तरीके से इस स्लाइड शो में आपको मैंने
बताने की कोशिश करी है। वही मैंने यहां पे
एक्सप्लेन करा है। तो इसमें होता क्या है
कि जैसे इंटरनल आपका ट्रस्टेड नेटवर्क है
जिसमें डेटाबेस सर्व्सर्स, एप्लीकेशन
सर्वर्स है, फाइल सर्वसर्स ये सारी चीजें
हैं। फिर आपका फायरवल है। इंटरनल फायरवल
जो है
सिक्योरिटी के लिए। देन आपका डीएमजी होता
है जो कि एक फ़िल्टर्ड ट्रैफिक होता है।
पेरीमीटर नेटवर्क एक एक एरिया नो पॉइंट 0
पॉइंट जो भी बोलो जहां जो कि वेब सर्वर
मेल सर्वर डीएनएस सर्वर जो यहां पे
फिल्टर्ड ट्रैफिक पहुंचती है। एंड देन
आपका एक्सटर्नल फायरवल होता है। देन आपका
इंटरनेट जो है जैसे बाहर की कोई ट्रैफिक
अगर आ रही है तो बाहर की ट्रैफिक जब आएगी
तो पहले एक्सटर्नल फायरवल अपने रूल के
अकॉर्डिंग उस ट्रैफिक को मेजर करेगा।
देखेगा कि भैया ऑपरेट करेगा। फिर वो जो
पर्टिकुलर पैकेट होगी वो डीएमजी में आ
जाएगी। जो आपका पेरामीटर नेटवर्क है
डीएमजी जो डिमिलिटराइज्ड ज़ोन है उसमें आ
जाएगी। वह एक फ़्टर्ड ट्रैफिक होगी कि भैया
हां यह फिल्टर्ड ट्रैफिक है। उसके बाद फिर
एक और इंटरनल नेट फायर वाल जो होगा वो
उसको फिर अपने रूल के अकॉर्डिंग कि भैया
मेरा इंटरनल फायर वाल पे क्या रूल सेटअप
है कि किसको अलऊ करना है जा के इंटरेक्ट
करने देना है हमें डेटाबेस सर्वर से
एप्लीकेशन सर्वर से या फाइल सर्वर से वो
ये फिक्स करेगा एंड तब जाके जो है पैकेट
पहुंचेगी आपके इंटरनल सिस्टम्स के ऊपर में
या जो भी सिस्टम्स है उसके ऊपर में। तो ये
एक सिक्योरिटी फीचर है। ये एक पूरा से
प्रोसेस सिक्योरिटी प्रोसेस है फायरवॉल
का। किस तरीके से फायरवॉल सिक्योर रखती है
कनेक्ट कनेक्शंस को आउटबाउंड इनबाउंड
कनेक्शंस को। इस तरीके से ये काम करती है।
ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
इनबाउंड आउटबाउंड दोनों सेम ही है।
आउटबाउंड का मतलब बाहर से ट्रैफिक आ रही
है। इनबाउंड का मतलब है आपके साइड से कोई
रिक्वेस्ट या कोई पैकेट जा रही है तो आपका
इंटरनल फायर वाल उसी के बेसिस पे उसको
प्रोसेस करेगा। देन यहां फिल्टर ट्रैफिक
आपकी पहुंचेगी। देन वो बाहर की तरफ जाएगा।
क्योंकि बाहर की तरफ भी जो ट्रैफिक जा रही
है वो भी किसी ना किसी सर्वर के से
इंटैक्ट कर रही है ना। किसी ना किसी
डिवाइस से इंटैक्ट कर रही है। तो वो भी तो
सेफ रहना चाहिए ना। बस आप ही का थोड़ी ना
सेफ रहना चाहिए। आपका डिवाइस या आपका
कंप्यूटर बाहर वाला जो कंप्यूटर है बाहर
वाला सर्वर है वो भी सेफ रहना चाहिए। वो
आपका जो इनबाउंड कनेक्शन बेसिकली जो सॉरी
ये इनबाउंड है जो मैंने अभी आपको बताया
इनबाउंड था जो बाहर से अंदर की तरफ आ रहा
था और जो अंदर से बाहर की तरफ जा रहा है
वो आउटबाउंड है। ठीक है? जो आप कहीं और
भेज रहे हैं तो वो आउटबाउंड है। थोड़ा वो
स्वाइप हो गया था उसको इग्नोर कीजिएगा।
ठीक है?
गॉट इट समझ में आ गया?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। आई होप यू अंडरस्टुड। राइट? अब एसओसी
इंडिकेटर की बात करें तो ब्लॉक्ड अटैक
अटेम्प्ट्स होते हैं। मतलब अटैक
अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं उनको ब्लॉक किया जा
रहा है। पोर्ट स्कैनिंग जो है वह आपको
दिखेगी। सस्िशियस आउटबाउंड ट्रैफिक दिखेगा
कि भैया मतलब बाहर की तरफ कोई आउटबन
ट्रैफिक बना रहा है। कुछ गड़बड़ कर रहा है
वो दिखेगा। अब जैसे एग्जांपल में कह रहे
हैं पोर्ट 3389 अटेम्प्ट्स 500 बार हुए
हैं। एक्शन एक्शन जो है डिनाइड हुआ है।
इसका मतलब है आरडीपी ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक हो
रहा है यहां पे। क्योंकि 3389 आरडीपी
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल का पोर्ट नंबर
होता है। इस पे 500 बार ट्राई हुआ है।
मतलब कि उसको डिनाई तो किया गया है लेकिन
ये ब्रूटफोर्स हो करने की कोशिश की जा रही
है हमारे रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल पे
आरडीपी के ऊपर में। तो ये पूरा एसओसी का
एग्जांपल आपका हो गया एक इंडिकेटर के साथ।
ठीक है?
ओके। आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ गया हो।
हां। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब हम आते
हैं हमारे एक और इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक पे।
आईडीएस या आईपीएस। अब देखो आईडीएस या
आईपीएस इसको थोड़ा समझ लेते हैं। यह क्या
होते हैं? बेसिकली आईडीएस जो होते हैं वह
होते हैं इंट्रूजन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम।
आईपीएस जो होते हैं वह होते हैं इंट्रूजन
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम। कई लोग ना इसको फेयरवल
समझते हैं। देखो कई लोग क्या होते हैं?
आईडीएस और आईपीएस को फेयरवल समझते हैं। आप
लोगों में से कितने लोग हैं जो अभी तक
जानते थे? ईमानदारी से बताइए। समझते थे कि
आईडीएस और आईपीएस फायर होता है।
ईमानदारी से बताओ।
बहुत लोग ऐसे समझते हैं कि आईडीएस और
आईपीएस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो है वो
फायरल होते हैं। बट एक्चुअली नहीं होते
हैं। देखो आईडीएस का फुल फॉर्म है
इंट्रोसेंट डिटेक्शन सिस्टम। इसी से
तुम्हें समझ में आ गया होगा। तो इसका मतलब
क्या होता है? इसका काम क्या होगा?
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम। इससे इसका काम समझ में
आ गया होगा। आइडिया जो है वो डिटेक्ट करता
है किसी भी तरह के अटैक्स को, किसी भी तरह
के मतलब मलेशियस अटेमप्ट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] को। प्रिवेंशन
जो है उसको काउंटर मेजर करता है। वहीं पे
जो है उसको बेसिकली ब्लॉक करता है। उसको
काउंटर मेजर उसका करता है। एंड उसको ड्रॉप
करता है। यह उसको प्रिवेंट करता है। बस
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आर द नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स दैट प्रोटेक्ट अगेंस्ट
साइबर थ्रेट्स। साइबर थ्रेट्स जितने भी
हैं उसके अगेंस्ट प्रोटेक्शन देता है
हमारा आईडीएस एंड आईपीएस। तो आईडीएस क्या
करता है? पैसिवली मॉनिटर ट्रैफिक। होस्ट
से इंटैक्ट नहीं करता। पैसिवली करता है
ये। मॉनिटर ट्रैफिक ट्रैफिक को मॉनिटर
करेगा। एंड अलर्ट्स ऑन सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी। और सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी पे
अलर्ट भी करेगा। कोई सस्पिशियस एक्टिविटी
हुई है तो उसको तुरंत अलर्ट करेगा। व्हाइल
आईपीएस सीट्स इन लाइन टू एक्टिवली ड्रॉप
मेशियस पैकेट्स एंड ब्लॉक थ्रेट्स इन रियल
टाइम। और आईपीएस क्या होता है? जो
प्रिवेंस सिस्टम है वो एक नेटवर्क के
कनेक्टिविटी के इनलाइन होता है। मतलब कि
जैसे आपका राउटर स्विच से कनेक्ट है,
स्विच आपका डिवाइसेस से कनेक्ट है, फिर
आपका बीच में फायरवल है वैसे उसी तरह से
बीच में आईपीएस बैठा रहता है। आईडीएस साइड
में बैठा रहता है। आईपीएस एकदम सबके बीच
में ऐसे ही कनेक्शन बनाए रहता है। और वो
रियल टाइम में क्या करता है कि मलेशियस
पैकेट्स जो हो गए हैं या जो कोई कोई ऐसे
थ्रेट हो गया उन सबको ब्लॉक करता है। उनको
ड्रॉप करता है। यही डिफरेंस है दोनों में
आईडीएस और आईपीएस। बस यही काम है आईडीएस
आईपीएस का दे आर ऑफेन इंटीग्रेटेड इंटू
नेक्स्ट जनरेशन फायरवॉल्स और यूनिफाइड
थ्रेट मैनेजमेंट डिवाइसेस। अब कुछ नेक्स्ट
जनरेशन जैसे फायरव्स होते हैं या जो भी
अभी लेटेस्ट आपके जो भी फायरव सॉल्यूशन
प्रोवाइड प्रोवाइडर्स होते हैं वो जनरली
सब में ये इंटीग्रेटेड होते हैं आईडीएस
आईपीएस आपके एंड यूज़ में आते हैं। तो
आईडीएस में क्या होता है? डिटेक्ट करता है
अटैक को और अलर्ट करता है एसओसी को।
आईपीएस क्या होता है? डिटेक्ट और ब्लॉक
दोनों ही काम करते हैं आपके आईपीएस। ठीक
है? अब इसका मैं एक एग्जांपल के थ्रू
दिखाता हूं। देखो दोनों का डायग्राम देख
के आपको थोड़ा समझ में आ जाएगा बेसिकली कि
आईपीएस जो है ना वो नेटवर्क हायरार्की में
ही है। नेटवर्क हायरार्की का पार्ट है। वो
नेटवर्क हायरार्की में ही रहता है। जैसे
आपका बाहर का इंटरनेट हो गया। देन फायर
वाल राउटर या फायरवल राउटर हो गई। देन
यहां आईपीs है। देन स्विच एंड देन आपका
कंप्यूटर लैपटॉप जो भी है। और आईडीएस क्या
होता है? वो बेचारा थोड़ा साइड में मतलब
थोड़ा सा साइड में कनेक्टेड होता है। आपका
इंटरनेट फायरल राउटर हो गया। स्विच हो
गया। एंड पॉइंट हो गई। और स्विच से यहां
पे आईडीएस की जो है वो कनेक्ट करके एंड
उसको यूज़ किया जाता है कि हां ठीक है भैया
डिटेक्ट वगैरह करो। तो यह है आपका आईडीएस
एंड आईपीएस। बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा है। राइट?
ये बहुत इजी कांसेप्ट था। आई होप कि आपको
समझ में आया होगा। अगर एसओसी अलर्ट की बात
करें तो इसके रिगार्डिंग एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन, मैलवेयर ट्रैफिक या एक्सप्लइट
अटेम्प्ट्स ये सब चीजें देखने को मिल सकती
हैं। और एसओसी चैलेंज की बात करें तो इस
आईडीएस आईपीएस के केस में फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स
बहुत ज्यादा आती हैं। कई बार ऐसा होता है
कि कोई ऐसी
पैकेट जो आपको अलाउड होनी चाहिए उसको
ड्रॉप करने का आपको आ जाएगा कि मलेशियस का
नोटिफिकेशन आ जाएगा। तो ये फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स बहुत होती है। अलर्ट फाइटिंग
मतलब बहुत अलर्ट्स आते हैं। जब आईडीएस
आईपीएस की अगर अलर्ट्स की बात करें तो
क्योंकि रेगुलर बहुत ट्रैफिक फ्लो होता
रहता है और उसमें कई ऐसे फॉल्स पॉजिटिव भी
होते हैं और आपको अलर्ट फैटिक दिया भी हो
सकते हैं। मतलब बहुत सारे अलर्ट्स उसी में
ट्रू वाला भी है, फॉल्स वाला भी है। तो एक
के बाद एक के बाद अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं। तो
यह एक अलर्ट फैटिक भी होता है आईडियास
आईपीएस के केस में।
ये आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट?
ओके। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम
नेट फिल्टर
हां बिल्कुल मोस्टली फॉल्स पॉजिटिव से आते
हैं क्योंकि
फायर है। फायरवॉल
रूल्स के ऊपर काम कर रहे हैं। ऑब्वियस सी
बात है। अब आते हैं हम यहां पे प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर्स के बीच। प्रॉक्सी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर्वर्स के ऊपर
बात करते हैं। एक्सैक्टली प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर्सर्स क्या होते हैं? देखो
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स जो होते हैं ना
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वह यूजर और
इंटरनेट के बीच में बैठे रहते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यूजर और इंटरनेट के बीच में जैसे यूजर हो
गया प्रॉक्सी हो गई एंड इंटरनेट हो गया।
बट बात अब यह है कि वीpए भी तो यूजर और
इंटरनेट के बीच में बैठा होता है। जब वीpए
के बीच जब वीpए के बारे में मैंने बताया
था तो यह देखो यहां भी मैंने बताया था
कि क्या होता है यह टनल बिटवीन यूजर एंड अ
नेटवर्क। यूजर और नेटवर्क के बीच में एक
टनल है बीच में बैठा बीच में है। उसी
तरीके से यहां पे आपका प्रॉक्सी भी जो है
यूजर और इंटरनेट के बीच में प्रॉक्सी होता
है। लेकिन यह दोनों में फिर एक्चुअली
डिफरेंस क्या है? वो बताना बहुत जरूरी है
ताकि आपका आपको क्लेरिटी एक मिले। आपको
एकदम क्लियर समझ में आए कि एक्सैक्टली है
क्या ये? देखो द कोर डिफरेंस इज़ दैट
वीपीएंस इंक्रिप्ट ऑल इंटरनेट ट्रैफिक एट
द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लेवल। ऑफरिंग हाई
सिक्योरिटी एंड प्राइवेसी व्हाइल
प्रॉक्सीस टिपिकली डू नॉट इंक्रिप्ट डाटा
एंड ओनली वर्क एट द एप्लीकेशन लेवल
एग्जांपल ब्राउज़र ओनली ये मेन डिफरेंस है
कि जो वीpए होते हैं वो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लेवल पे काम करते हैं और जितने भी इंटरनेट
ट्रैफिक है उसको इंक्रिप्ट करते हैं और जो
आपके प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स हैं वह बेसिकली
आपके काम करते हैं एप्लीकेशन लेवल पे एंड
ब्राउज़र लेवल पे एंड वह इंक्रिप्ट नहीं
करते हैं। तो वह दोनों के बीच का यह एक
हां, यह एक मेन डिफरेंस है जो दोनों को
अलग बनाती है। अब यहां पर और भी चीजें हैं
जो मैं आपको बताऊंगा। वीpएं आर आइडियल फॉर
टोटल सिक्योरिटी वेयर एज प्रॉक्सीस आर
फास्ट एंड बेटर फॉर सिंपल आईपी मास्किंग
और बायपासिंग Jio रेस्ट्रिकशंस। अब देखो
वीpए कंप्लीट अगर आपको सिक्योरिटी चाहिए
जो कि मैंने आपको पहले बताया कुछ टाइम
पहले कि क्या सिक्योरिटी है कंप्लीट। बट
स्टिल अगर आपको ज्यादा सिक्योरिटी चाहिए
तो वीpए यूज़ कीजिए। बट प्रॉक्सी जो है वो
फास्टर होते हैं। उतनी ज्यादा सिक्योरिटी
प्रोवाइड तो नहीं करते हैं बट अगर सिंपल
आईपी मास्क करनी है और Jio रेस्ट्रिकशंस
वगैरह बाईपास करनी है तो ये जो आपकी
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्सर्स है वो यूज़ में आ जाती
है। ठीक है? वीpएं प्रोवाइड रोबस्ट
इंक्रिप्शन मेकिंग ट्रैफिक अनरीडेबल टू
आईएसपीस एंड हैकर्स। प्रॉक्सी जनरली
प्रोवाइड नो इंक्रिप्शन मीनिंग डाटा इज़
लेस सिक्योर। तो वीपीएंस का यह काम है कि
बेसिकली आईएसपी वगैरह से डाटा इंक्रिप्ट
करके रखती है तो आईएसपी डाटा रीड नहीं कर
पाएंगी या हैकर्स के लिए थोड़ा मुश्किल हो
जाएगा और प्रॉक्सी जो है वो जनरली
इंक्रिप्शन का कुछ खास होता नहीं है तो
डाटा जो है वो सिक्योर कम होगा। अब अब
इसको हम आगे भी और देखेंगे यहां पे दो तरह
के प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स होते हैं। बट इसके
पहले मैं आपको एक चीज बताना चाहूंगा। जैसे
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर का यूज़ ना ऐसे जनरली भी
लार्ज नेटवर्क के अंदर भी किया जाता है।
जैसे कि अ मान लो कि ये कोई नेटवर्क है
कंप्यूटर कंप्यूटर। अब उसने क्या किया?
अपने सर्वर के आगे एक प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
सेटअप करके रख दिया। एक प्रॉक्सी सर्वर
सेटअप करके रख दिया जिसको हम रिवर्स
प्रॉक्सी प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स बोलते हैं। तो
एक सर्वर के आगे रख दिया कि ताकि जब यूजर
कोई रिक्वेस्ट करे ना तो हमारे प्रॉक्सी
सर्वर पे ही वो रिक्वेस्ट आए सारे। हमारे
मेन सर्वर पे लोड कम पड़े। ऐसा भी होता
है। एक यह भी एक इसका वर्किंग प्रिंसिपल
है।
तो इसको हम समझने के लिए आगे हम फॉरवर्ड
एंड रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी को थोड़ा समझते हैं।
यह क्या एक्सक्टली होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] फॉरवर्ड
प्रॉक्सी सट इन द इन फ्रंट ऑफ क्लाइंट्स
टू मैनेज आउटबाउंड रिक्वेस्ट्स। ठीक है?
मतलब जो क्लाइंट्स आपके होते हैं जैसे आप
हो गया, आपका ब्राउज़र हो गया, आपका
कंप्यूटर हो गया, लैपटॉप हो गया। उसके बाद
एक फ़ॉरवर्ड प्रॉक्सी होती है, जो आपके
रिक्वेस्ट्स को हैंडल करती है। आप जैसे
आपने कोई Google से रिक्वेस्ट किया,
Facebook से रिक्वेस्ट किया, तो आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट इस फ़ॉरवर्ड प्रॉक्सी से होते
हुए फिर नेटवर्क लेयर के होते हुए आगे फिर
दूसरे बाहर इंटरनेट की तरफ जाएगी।
प्रोवाइडिंग एनोनिमिटी एंड कंटेंट
फ़िल्टरिंग। यह एक आपको फैसिलिटी प्रोवाइड
करता है कि आपकी आईपी मास्किंग वगैरह कर
देता है। जैसे अगर फॉरवर्ड प्रॉक्सी है
आपने लगा के रखा हुआ है तो अब जब भी आप
कोई रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे तो आपकी इस इन
सिस्टम्स की आईपी को यूज़ ना करके यह
फॉरवर्ड प्रॉक्सी जो है वो एक डिफरेंट
आईपी को यूज़ करेगा। एंड वहां पे आपकी आईपी
मास्किंग हो जाती है। थोड़ी बहुत लेवल की
एनमिटी वगैरह आपको मिल जाती है। एंड फिर
आपकी रिक्वेस्ट जो है आगे की तरफ फ़ॉरवर्ड
होती है। जबकि रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी जो है वो
सट इन फ्रंट ऑफ़ सर्वर्स। रिवर्स प्रॉक्सीस
इसके उल्टा है। यह सर्वर्स के साइड से
होते हैं। सर्वर के सामने बैठे रहते हैं।
टू हैंडल इनकमिंग रिक्वेस्ट्स, मैनेजिंग
लोड बैलेंसिंग, कैशिंग एंड सिक्योरिटी। अब
क्या करते हैं कि ये सर्वर्स के बिहाफ में
काम करते हैं। रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स कि
अब जैसे रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है यूजर की तरफ
से आई है मान लो यहां पे। तो अब रिवर्स
प्रॉक्सी की तरफ सारी रिक्वेस्ट आएंगी। अब
ये सारी रिक्वेस्ट रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी हमारा
सर्व करेगा। सर्वर से इसने ले ली फाइल। अब
इसको सर्व करेगा ये रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी। तो
जितना भी लोड है वो रिवर्स प्रॉक्सीस पे आ
जाएंगी। अब मान लो कि सर्वर एक ही है। मान
लो कि सर्वर हमारा एक ही है और इसने यहां
पे मल्टीपल रिवर्स प्रॉक्सीस जो है वो लगा
के रखे हैं। तो इससे होता क्या है? लोड
बैलेंसिंग भी होता है कि जैसे मान लो कोई
एक वेबसाइट है जिसप बहुत ट्रैफिक आ रही
है। तो अब एक रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी लगी हुई है।
फिर एक और रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी लगी हुई है।
ऐसे करके मल्टीपल रिवर्स प्रॉक्सीस के ऊपर
सारे लोड जाएंगे। सर्वर्स के ऊपर जो मेन
सर्वर है उसके ऊपर लोड कम पड़ जाता है। तो
यह लोड बैलेंसिंग का काम होता है।
एडब्ल्यूएस लोड बैलेंसर्स भी कुछ इसी
तरीके से काम करते हैं। जब आप एडब्ल्यूएस
वगैरह को यूज़ करेंगे कभी फ्यूचर में या
करते होंगे तो वहां लोड बैलेंसर भी होती
है। लोड बैलेंसर भी आप सर्विस यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। तो बेसिकली वहां पे मल्टीपल
प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स होती है एंड उसको यूज़
किया जाता है। यूजर को दिया जाता है कि
भैया आपकी जो ट्रैफिक है जो जो भी ट्रैफिक
है वो पहले प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स के ऊपर आएंगी
और फिर मेन सर्वर के तो मेन सर्वर के ऊपर
जो लोड है वो थोड़ा कम पड़ेगा। तो ये एक
अच्छा लोड बैलेंसिंग का भी काम कर दिया।
एक कैशिंग मतलब सारी जो कैश हो रही है
डिटेल्स वो रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी सर्वर कैश कर
रहा है। सर्वर को कैश करने की जरूरत नहीं
है। सर्वर का कैश मेमोरी नहीं फुल होगा।
सर्वर की कैश मेमोरी बची रहेंगी। और
सिक्योरिटी जो होती है थोड़ी बहुत वो तो
आपकी हो ही जा रही है कि कोई अटैक अगर हो
रहा है तो डायरेक्ट सर्वर पे अटैक ना होके
रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी के ऊपर अटैक हो रहा है।
सर्वर हमारा वैसे ही इंटैक्ट है। सर्वर की
सिक्योरिटी मेंटेंड है। यह एक डिॉवर्ड और
रिवर्स प्रॉक्सीस के बीच का डिफरेंस होता
है। आर यू गेटिंग गाइस? समझ में आ रहा है
आपको?
आर यू गेटिंग?
प्रॉक्सी और वीpए का डिफरेंस नहीं समझ में
आया। बहुत ईजी। मैंने पहले ही बताया कि
प्रॉक्सी जो होती है वो अनइंक्रिप्टेड
ट्रैफिक को के लिए होती है। जो कि बेसिकली
क्या होता है? इंक्रिप्शन प्रोवाइड नहीं
करती है। वीpए जो है वो इंक्रिप्शन
प्रोवाइड करते हैं। ज्यादा सिक्योर होते
हैं। प्रॉक्सीस थोड़ी फास्ट होती है।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
ओके? यह [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] तो समझ
में आ गया होगा। अब
थोड़ी देर और रुक जाओ फॉर स्कल बस थोड़ी
देर। ठीक है? ये होती है फॉरवर्ड एंड
रिवर्स प्रॉक्सेस। तो प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स जो
है दो टाइप के आपके फॉरवर्ड प्रॉक्सी
सर्वसर्स रिवर्स प्रॉक्सी सर्वर्स जो
मैंने आपको बताया।
ठीक है? अब एसओसी लॉग्स में देखें तो
यूआरएल्स एक्सेस्ड ऐसे लॉग्स आएंगे कुछ
ऐसे कि यूआरएल एक्सेस किए गए हैं। यूआरएल
बहुत सारे यूआरएल्स एक्सेस किए गए हैं।
यूजर की एक्टिविटी के बारे में और डाउनलोड
या अपलोड के बारे में आपको आएगी। इसे
एसोसिएट इंडिकेटर्स की अगर हम बात करें तो
एक्सेस टू मशियस डोमेनस मलेशियस डोमेन का
एक्सेस करना। डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन डेटा को
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट करना। अनयूजुअल ब्राउजिंग
ब्राउजिंग कर रहे हैं। अनयूजुअल ब्राउजिंग
हो रही है। डाटा बहुत ज्यादा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट चुराया जा रहा है या निकाला
जा रहा है। ये सारी चीजें एसओसी
इंडिकेटर्स का यह काम करती है। ठीक है?
एसओसी इंडिकेटर में आपको ये चीजें देखने
को मिल सकती हैं।
9:00 बजे एक और क्लास है। बट थोड़ी देर और
रुक जाओ। बस थोड़ी देर में हमारी खत्म
होगी यहां पे। अब यहां पे हम आते हैं
प्रॉक्सी सर्विस का मैं सारी चीजें अगर
मैं कंबाइन कर दूं। सारे फ्लो को मैं
कंबाइन अगर कर दूं तो कुछ इस तरीके का
फ्लो बना है। जो भी हमने अभी तक करा जो भी
हमने अभी तक सीखा। तो सारे फ्लो को अगर हम
कंबाइन कर देते हैं तो एक यूजर है पहले
यूजर मतलब ये इनसाइड आउटसाइड जा रहा है
नेटवर्क इनसाइड आउटसाइड ये फ्लो चल रहा है
कि आपके घर से शुरू हो रहा है ये फ्लो तो
आप घर पे एक यूजर है देन स्विच से
कनेक्टेड है मान लो फिर वो राउटर से
कनेक्टेड है फिर वो फायरवल से कनेक्टेड है
देन वहां पे प्रॉक्सी सर्स है देन इंटरनेट
है कुछ इस तरीके से यानी यूजर और इंटरनेट
के बीच में ये सारी चीजें काम कर रही हैं।
तो राउटर जो है वो IP ट्रैफिक के लिए होता
है। अगर हम एसओसी के टर्म्स में देखें तो
एक एसओसी एल1 जो होता है एसओसी एनालिस्ट
वह क्या देखता है किस लिए यूज़ करता है
राउटर को आईपी ट्रैफिक के लिए स्विच को
मैक एक्टिविटी के लिए फायरवल को अलाउड या
ब्लॉक ट्रैफिक के लिए ट्रैफिक को अलाउड
ब्लॉक के लिए आईडीएस आईपीएस अटैक्स
अलर्ट्स के लिए कोई भी अटैक हो रहा है
उसके अलर्ट्स के लिए और प्रॉक्सी जो है
यूजर के बिहेवियर के लिए या फिर लोड
बैलेंसिंग के लिए ये सारी चीजें जो है ये
आपकी एक समरी थी जो हम हमने अभी तक जितने
ने भी चीजें करी। राउटर के बारे में पढ़ा,
स्विच के बारे में पढ़ा, फायरल के बारे
में पढ़ा, आईडीएस आईपीs के बारे में पढ़ा,
वीpए के बारे में पढ़ा, प्रॉक्सीस के बारे
में पढ़ा। ये सारे टॉपिक्स हमने करे हैं।
सर 50 के होने वाले हैं आपके। हां हां जी
भाई 50 के होने वाले हैं। बहुत अच्छी बात
है। आप लोगों के कारण 50 के सब्सक्राइबर्स
पॉसिबल होगा अभी। लगभग 49000 49500 लगभग
होने वाले हैं। तो बहुत कम बच गए हैं
50000 में एंड इट्स अ बिग थिंग फॉर एव्री
डिफ्रॉनिकस्टर्स एंड एवरीवन सपोर्टिंग अस
एंड आर वि अस टिल नाउ थैंक यू वेरी मच टू
एवरीबॉडी। ओके तो ये सब कंबाइन किया तो
हमने ये सारी चीज़ हो गई। अगर हम यहां पे
अब बात करते हैं रियल एसओसी सिनेरियो की
अगर तो यूज़र डाउनलोड फ़ाइल्स फ़्रॉम अननोन
डोमेन फायरवल अलाउड है। प्रॉक्सी सस्िशियस
यूआरएल आईडीएस ने क्या किया? मालवेयर
डिटेक्ट किया है। कंक्लूजन क्या है?
मालवेयर इंस्पेक्शन अटेम्प्ट हुआ है यहां
पे। ठीक है? मालवेयर सॉरी मैलवेयर
इंफेक्शन अटेम्प्ट हुआ है। मालवेयर से
इनफेक्ट करने की अटेम्प्ट हुई है यहां पे।
एक रियल एसोसिएशन सिनेरियो में करें। तो
अननोन डोमेन से डाउनलोड किया गया है।
फायरवल में अलऊ कर दिया गया है उसको एंड
प्रॉक्सी सस्िशियस यूआरएल डिटेक्ट करती है
कि भैया ये तो सस्पिशियस यूआरएल हो सकती
है और आईडीएस बोलता है कि मैलवेयर
डिटेक्टेड तो यहां पे एक मैलवेयर इंफेक्शन
अटेम्प्ट हुई है कि आपके पूरे सिस्टम को
मैलवेयर से इनफेक्ट कर दिया जाए। यह ट्राई
हुआ है। एक अगर एनालिस्ट की थिंकिंग की
बात करें तो व्हेन अलर्ट कम्स जब भी कोई
अलर्ट आए तो आपको क्या पूछना है? वेयर डिड
दिस हैपन? वेयर डिड दिस हैपन? यह पूछना है
इस केस में कहां हुआ था यह? तो अगर इंटरनल
के बाद के केस में बात करें तो स्विच या
मैक हो गई जो लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क की लाइन
की बात करें नेटवर्क की बात करें बाहर
मतलब बाहर के नेटवर्क की तो राउटर एंड
आईपी हो गए सिक्योरिटी की बात करें तो
फायरवल या आईडीएस आईपीएस हो गई यूजर की
बात करें तो यहां पे प्रॉक्सी की बात हो
गई तो ये पूछना है आपको वेयर डिड इट हैपन
यूजर के केस में हुआ है सिक्योरिटी या
नेटवर्क या इंटरनल हुआ है ये सारी चीज़ तो
ये एक एनालिस्ट थिंकिंग को डिनोट करती है
कि अगर आप एक एनालिस्ट हैं तो कुछ इस
तरीके से आपको सोचना चाहिए यू हैव यू शुड
बी थिंकिंग लाइक दिस कि कोई अटैक हुआ है।
कोई अलर्ट हुआ कोई अलर्ट आया है बेसिकली
तो आपको देखना है कि भैया इंटरनल है वह
कुछ अटैक या एक्सटर्नल है या फिर
सिक्योरिटी का कुछ सिक्योरिटी थ्रेट है
कुछ अलग तरीके की या कोई यूजर का कुछ ऐसा
बिहेवियर है जो सस्िशियस है। ये सारी
चीजें आपको देखनी होती है। सो दिस ऑल
टॉपिक्स जो आज हमने कवर करा बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक्स थे। बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स थे। इसके बाद ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं है। हमारा जो ओएस पार्ट है और
साइबर सिक्योरिटी के एक दो टॉपिक जो हैं
डीएनएस और अ एपीटी एडवांस एडवांस
पर्सिस्टेंट थ्रेट ये हम करेंगे। उसके बाद
हमारा ओएस वाला चीज है वो हो जाएगा। देन
हमारा सारा कंप्लीट देन एसओसी वाली चीजें
के लिए बस 10 से 12 क्लासेस लगेंगी एंड वो
खत्म हो जाएंगी आपकी। उसके बाद हमारा ये
ट्रेनिंग भी खत्म हो जाएगा। एंड मोस्टली
मैं ट्राई कर रहा हूं कि इस ट्रेनिंग को
जल्दी टाइमली खत्म कर दिया जाए। एंड आपके
लिए एक परफेक्ट ट्रेनिंग हो जाएगी। फिर
उसके बाद जो है आप इसको फॉलो कर सकते हैं
एंड आगे बढ़ सकते हैं। ठीक है? चलिए। सो
आई होप कि आज की क्लास आपको
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] इंटरेस्टिंग लगी
होगी, समझ में भी आ गया होगा आपको। मजे
मजे आए होंगे टॉपिक्स समझने में एंड
अंडरस्टैंडिंग रही होगी सबकी। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। सो यहां पे
यहां पे टॉप फेंस की लिस्ट देख लेते हैं
एक बार। जैसे मैंने बोला यहां पर मैं
हमेशा टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट दिखा देता हूं।
कभी-कभी भूल जाता हूं। तो यह टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट है भैया। थैंक यू वेरी मच एवरीबॉडी।
यहां पे ऊपर में यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
यहां पे ये टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट है। नाम
सबके मैं नहीं ले रहा क्योंकि नाम लेना
बहुत मुश्किल हो जाता है सबके नाम लेना।
यह लिस्ट है।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस ऑन गेटिंग इन द टॉप 10
लिस्ट क्योंकि आप लोग बहुत एक्टिव रहते
हैं। काफी कंटिन्यू रहते हैं। तो अच्छा
लगता है। यू गाइस कम हियर एंड यू गाइस
स्पेंड टाइम विथ मी एंड लर्न समथिंग
क्वालिटी क्वालिटी मजा आता है। ऐसे ही आप
कंटिन्यू करते रहिए। एंड ऐसे ही क्लासेस
आपकी आती रहेंगी। देन वी विल फिनिश दिस
एसओसी। हेलो।
थैंक यू सर। वेलकम वेलकम। सर्टिफिकेट कैसे
मिलेगा? सर्टिफिकेट के बारे में मैंने कभी
कुछ आपको नहीं बोला है। ना ही मैंने ऐसा
कुछ प्रॉमिस किया कि आपको सर्टिफिकेट दी
जा दी जाएंगी। बट हां सर्टिफिकेशन से
रिलेटेड डिटेल्स जरूर हम लेकर आएंगे। मैं
आपको सर्टिफिकेशन से रिलेटेड डिटेल्स जरूर
बताऊंगा। लाइक कि एग्जैक्टली क्या करना
है, कैसे करना है सर्टिफिकेट। हम किस तरह
की सर्टिफिकेट आपको प्रोवाइड करेंगे या
नहीं करेंगे या किस तरह के सर्टिफिकेट्स
हम ऑफर करेंगे। वो सारी चीजें हम आपको
बताएंगे। अभी पहले कोर्स कर लो। पहले जो
स्किल है, एक्चुअल स्किल है, उसको गेन
करो। सर्टिफिकेट साइड में करो। वह बाद की
चीज है यार। सर्टिफिकेट के ऊपर फोकस मत
करो। मैं एक यही चीज़ बोलूंगा। सर्टिफिकेट
के पीछे भागोगे कुछ नहीं हो पाएगा। वो फिर
वो लर्निंग नहीं हो पाएगी आपकी। लर्निंग
करो। सर्टिफिकेट तो आ ही जाएंगे जब आनी
होगी। राइट?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] ठीक है।
ठीक। अच्छा आफ्टर कंप्लीशन सर्टिफिकेट
मिलेगा या नहीं? अच्छा मतलब आप चाहते हो
कि मैं यहां पे बोलूं और फिर उसके बाद आप
मेरे पीछे पड़ जाओ। राइट? कि अरे सर आपने
ये बोला था वो बोला था। ऐसा कुछ भी नहीं
है। जब जो मिलनी होगी जो भी बातें होंगी
आपको आने वाले टाइम में अपडेट कर दी
जाएंगी एंड आपको उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल
जाएगी। ठीक है? सो बस गाइस आज के सेशन के
लिए फिलहाल इतना ही देन एंड आज की इस सेशन
को हम एंड करते हैं। थैंक यू सो मच फॉर
जॉइनिंग द सेशन। अच्छा लगा आपके साथ।
अच्छे टॉपिक्स हमने आज डील करे। कुछ और
टॉपिक्स बचे हैं जो हमने इस क्लास में
करेंगे। एंड आई होप कि आपने कुछ अच्छा नया
एंड कुछ ऑथेंटिक चीजें कुछ रियल चीजें
सीखी हैं। अपने स्किल्स जो हैं उसमें ऐड
करा है। सो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में
गाइस। थैंक यू वेरी मच। शुभ रात्रि। जाइए
खानावाना खाइए, मस्ती कीजिए एंड हम
नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिलेंगे। टाटा बाय-ब।